so i hate when you do that why
it sounds disgusting oh just the sound
of my thighs when i run
[Music]
is this how girls feel when they hear
the word moist
[Music]
oh god oh god it makes me feel dirty
stop it welcome to this episode of the
trash taste podcast uh where we talk
about not anime
but we might talk about anime today
actually who knows who knows
if are we feeling spicy today we'll
never tell
i might bring up anime and then
immediately tangent from
who knows who knows not even we do most
of the time what we're going to talk
about
this is like a themed episode i did i
did think what i was going to talk about
today because i was like connor you have
to think about what we're going to talk
about go on there go on then what
do you what do you want to talk about
you want to introduce us by the way
we're the boys
no i'm not introducing you they know who
you are right now we're on episode 49
they should know who you are nearly 15.
um but yeah no so uh a few weeks ago i
watched the
jojo event of course you did of course i
did where part six was announced
which is why everyone watched it because
they were like will part6 get announced
who knows man imagine if they didn't
announce part six after all that
i think it would have been very sad i
should probably explain uh if you're not
a jojo fan don't worry don't explain
basically there's a whole event around
jojo
uh they didn't say they were gonna
announce the new anime adaptation uh but
everyone was like
they said it's the biggest event in jojo
history so
i think they're going to announce it
otherwise i don't think this is the
biggest event do they normally do jojo
events
just randomly out of the blue i've never
heard of well this is this has been
planned for a very long time apparently
actually
right a year ago i think actually have
they done one before this
i feel like they have but then but then
if you go to youtube and you type in
jojo live on tv yeah they constantly get
the voice actors to do
kind of what they did in this event yeah
yeah um so i guess i'll walk you guys
through the event basically what
happened yeah cause i didn't get to
watch it i didn't get to watch it either
i just saw the reaction um yeah the
reactions we'll get into that
okay first of all the event
we weren't really told anything so you
didn't know anything that was happening
all we knew is that there was a
40 price tag to watch something like
three
pay-per-view pay-per-view yeah 40 bucks
jesus
wow which is uh little c you know eating
your heart out jake paul
and we were yeah right you shoot boxing
now jojo bed please
um but it was yeah it was a pay-per-view
and we weren't told anything before all
right we're just told it's going to be
the biggest event in jojo history
at a reverb as if they don't say that
for every event you know how they are in
japan i feel like they hyped things up
way beyond belief
yeah yeah again we weren't told anything
so essentially what happened was that
they did like kind of like a game show
kind of thing in the start with some of
the voice actors so
every uh main character joseph uh if you
don't know jojo don't really worry about
it's not important but they say the
voice actors they were like they quiz
them about the show it's kind of like
meh game show it's basic japanese tv
yeah yeah it was basically like family
feud but with the jojo character which
actually sounds really good actually
i could make that i want to watch it how
old did you do in the quiz well i i
i did we'll get into this okay okay
and then you know it was like cool and
the voice actors performed some of their
scenes which was like the best part
yeah yeah you know they would do uh uh
they would all do the most dramatic
scene from their respective
part in the show which is really good um
yeah and then in the end they announced
it and uh it went over the time so it's
supposed to be a two-hour event
and my god did they talk a lot they very
much it wasn't like a
like fast it was like let's just talk
about the show about the scenes
how did the scenes make you feel tell us
about it and yeah it was fine it's fine
um but there was a few things that were
noteworthy about the event
uh first of all uh is that the subtitles
were unusable
unreadable awful uh
so this i said this was a live event
yeah but a live event that was
pre-broadcast yeah like pre-recorded
yeah it was all
all yeah that broadcast sorry
pre-recorded totally um it was
i'm not sure if it was intentionally
gonna be so it's a live playback in
other words it's a live re
replaying it they basically just made a
youtube premiere
right yeah well right i mean that's
basically it right it was edited like a
live japanese tv show
where like it was very minimal i guess
minimal in terms of japanese editing and
stuff on screen right next time we do a
trash taste special
that we got to make that pay-per-view
now man we do we should be what are we
doing
we're [ __ ] dumb doing it for free
and it's self-funded oh my god
so yeah it was it was it was forty
dollars yeah
which you know for a live event yeah a
bit hefty and you can buy a whole season
of jojo on dvd for that or something
right yeah you should buy four episodes
of a jojo on blu-ray for that you know
um and don't get me wrong the event was
very good it was very well made
but it was just tragic because you know
how many events shot
40 dollars for you to watch them not a
lot i mean
maybe like a a concert of like a
mid-ranged artist is like 40 dollars
right but
online though yeah not online i feel
like boxing events
yeah i feel like the boxing ones are the
only ones that may be wrestling
uh or they're right i'm not like uh i
don't watch wrestling um but
those are the ones i think are yeah but
usually
usually it's like you know if you're
paying 40 bucks you have it's a in
person experience right
most of the time i would like to think
but with boxing as well they do it
online as well and it's always like a
[ __ ] 80 bucks now oh yeah
yeah i mean i feel like with boxing it's
different to a lot of sporting of
other sporting events because people
like you're building up months and
months this
one moment whereas other things like
football
or you know basketball there's like
constant matches throughout the season
right but with boxing you have one event
that people build up months to
and that's it so i can i can understand
the pay-per-view price or that model
kind of
in that kind of sense and boxing fans
are hardcore this is what i think like
do i not understand the japanese market
enough because i'm like is this like the
same level as a
like a international boxing event in
japan like this jojo event is it like
the same level of like
everyone is everyone's stopping what
they're doing right well you know jojo
fans are
yeah but i wonder i wonder if this is
like is this
the price is this high because they're
banking on jojo fans being as dedicated
as they are which they are which they
are yeah um or is it that they think
it's that big of an event in general in
japan i mean
i feel like i feel like it's a japanese
business model period because i feel
like it's the only country that can sell
blu-rays for like hundreds of dollars
for like four episodes sometimes yeah
for a special edition and
people here will still buy it yeah and
uh
watching this live event was fun because
the live tweets were quite quite
interesting people were not very happy
all right um on the english it was
really yeah it was really yeah english
it was really interesting seeing how
all the negativity got wiped away the
moment that like part six was announced
and everyone's like guys guys it's worth
it it was the event was worth it two
hours of [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah because this is so essentially
right uh the again it was it was
pre-recorded so this could have been
subtitled
like properly it's not you know you can
get budget
subtitles and translations done you know
for this kind of
length like you know we get subtitles
done for the podcast i think yeah
to get the the podcast captioned it's
like 150
an episode uh but if you wanted to
translate it i think it would be
into japanese for like an episode like
this which i think is around the same
length
is like maybe like 800 bucks yeah so
it's not in terms of a big business
800 bucks for that kind of thing for
like low end translating
yeah not that much right yeah but
instead they decided for some reason to
do
auto-generated subtitles and never a
good sign there was like there was like
people were just posting screenshots of
the subtitles like i'm going to kill a
kid or something
or something like really funny out of
context like
it was just really bad yeah to the point
where it was like
this is unwatchable if you don't know
any japanese
like the subtitles are so bad and it was
just like i just wondered why
like this is such a good event like you
have a if you're a jojo fan this event
was amazing
yeah yeah it's the kind of stuff that if
it was on youtube it had like five
million views guaranteed yeah
i'm wondering like do you think they
even thought about the international
audience
or were they just really marketing
towards the japanese audience i don't
think
like even me living in japan i only
heard about it like the day before and
that's because
you [ __ ] posted about it like i did
not know
like this wasn't talked about at all on
my timeline at least so i didn't know
about it until just as it was happening
yeah
if if this was an event right where they
it was
only really able you're only able to pay
in yen you were only able to buy from a
japanese website yeah i would
i would be like that's a fair argument
you know you went on the job yeah
you went out of your way to pay in the
currency you're expected
if they don't understand the word that's
fine but for me it was like all right so
they're premiering the show in like
uh singapore us specifically they have
website in english
charging you in dollar and they're
telling you that it's going to be
subtitled
i think it's kind of [ __ ] up like yeah
the event was great and it's just so sad
that they kind of i feel like they
mislead people a bit oh yeah absolutely
i mean when have automated subtitles
ever worked
they barely work for for captioning the
language that
they're doing yeah they barely work for
our own language when we upload it on
youtube right there's auto subtitles
what were they thinking yeah it's been
known to be one of the hardest languages
to translate into english yeah
i think completely different
grammatically i think in terms of uh
cost per like uh
like per minute of translating japanese
to english is one of the most expensive
i'm not surprised by that because it's
the hardest and there's not there's not
many people that can do it it's
grammatically completely different
right so then who decided that they
should be like this is a great idea
and we're gonna charge forty dollars for
this i mean i i would think for
a forty dollar price you would get like
more professional subtitles
like because i i guess this is the first
i'm hearing about this but like when i
hear live events i think you know
you you you understand there's some
leeway in an actual live event
where it's happening right as it's
airing right but if it was
pre-recorded then yeah i mean you could
have you could there was
there was nothing about this show that
needed to be live yeah there was
there was no aspect of it that required
a live well
yeah if it's pre-recorded then like it's
not like it's not like the host can
interact with the chat or
anything like that right so you're
telling me you paid 40 dollars just to
see a part 6 announcement
yeah and i'd do it again
jojo fans are offensive
i would have got like five minutes later
anyway but you know
i don't know i you know i sat down i was
like this isn't 40 dollars yeah yeah
just the subtitles the subtitles it's
just it's like you know
at what point is it like do i need a
refund you know what i mean
how bad do the subtitles have to be
where it's like i can't understand
anything that's being said well i mean i
think that's
worthy of a refund right like you you
paid for something that you didn't even
really
understand yeah yeah and they didn't
even like give you the chance to try and
understand it was really unfortunate as
well because people were like dogging on
them on twitter and then the
jojo anime account yeah tweeted out
being like hey guys
uh because there was a lot of people
streaming it on twitch right and they
were like guys please don't pirate it
there
and then there was one this is like i
feel like as a company you should never
ever say this you should never ever say
the words there is no excuse to pirates
right because
i guarantee within 10 seconds there is
going to be 10 people with 10
semi-decent reasons why they pirated it
so for example
and this is terrible so this show was
only available
in the us uh singapore and i think a few
other asian countries
yeah yeah no europe no europe at all
right no none of the other american
countries nothing
not even not even canada not even canada
so they were like
this in this tweet they said there is no
excuse to pirate
this thing yeah and then in brackets
they said
sorry for the territory limitations and
i'm thinking like
oh no so what is it what is a european
fan supposed to do
yeah every europeans unanimously feels
like a european
what am i supposed to do tell me what i
chose to do i'd just just be born better
yeah
just just just be born in a better
country obviously
obviously come on obviously i'm not i'm
not promoting piracy
yeah but there is a way as a company
where you can word things or go about it
just fly to asia so you can watch it
from asia during a pandemic
just live in japan just just leave it do
you like anime just live in japan
it's just it's so frustrating because it
feels like
i mean it feels like this yeah i mean
this i feel like companies
should already have a understanding that
like territory limitations are like i i
in my opinion
the the biggest reason why people
pirates absolutely and it's it's been
like this
since [ __ ] the internet was invented
basically
like lost media i firmly believe you
know you should be able to
if it's abandoned where or or completely
lost and there's no you know i
honestly i think that's okay to pirate i
i don't like why would that not be okay
like
no one has a stake in this anymore yeah
like like isn't like
playstation or sony shutting down the
ps3
psp yeah ps vita stores now yeah so like
you know
even though even though like you know i
cause i own i own a ps vita and
when i heard that i was like [ __ ] what
if there's a game that i want on the ps
vita i don't know what it is now yeah
but like i'm not gonna be able to obtain
it
it's it's just lost media now right yeah
and if you're not gonna make it readily
available
then someone's gonna archive this
you know and i it's it's
it's it's a it's a gray area but i feel
like there is
you know there is a reason why people do
want to pyramid do you want to like
archive this stuff there's definitely
like
it's not a matter of like oh there's
there's no excuse to pirate when it's
like
no there really is an excuse to pirate
because it's literally
the only way i'll ever be able to get a
hand on it right i mean it's like
if you you would get someone who gets
into your product
who never would have been able to and
never would have had a chance to yeah
right and again with this live stream
it's like why is this live stream only
in
some countries like is it because
they're perhaps showing scenes from the
anime is it probably a lie
probably is actually it's probably a
licensing thing but still it's like
it's it's a live stream you know i mean
it's not like you can't get it in every
country
i mean i mean i feel like that kind of
mentality just hasn't
adapted to just how the internet works
and just
how the camera works now in 2021 or even
[ __ ]
2010 yeah because all the laws are just
yeah yeah all right all like the laws
are like completely outdated
because they're all laws that are made
for like television broadcasts and stuff
like that right especially in japan
yeah especially in japan it just wasn't
i mean we don't even have fair use laws
here
yeah which is ridiculous well i mean
it's it's i feel like at least in the us
there is a a mentality of okay well
technically you know live streaming a
game and not paying
the the you know for a license to do
that yeah just technically
you know legally speaking you're not
allowed to do that yeah but all the us
companies just kind of agreed it's
beneficial let them do it yeah but i
feel like exactly
that thing doesn't really happen no
there's not a there's there's not really
a thing of
it's beneficial so let them do it you
know it's just another you know
it's like when you get events like this
you're just reminded that you know
you're another one of those anime fans
uh being westerner that yeah they don't
care about you
i mean i mean i i feel like the
mentality is slowly i mean it took
this long for it to change with like
western companies so god you know
it's gonna change with japanese it is
changing out of [ __ ] snails for sure
i mean like i would say at least
japanese companies know that we exist
now
that's that's that's that's the biggest
difference right because imagine like
five years ago where
they had a american or they had like an
english site to promote a japanese
livestream you know we are taking
very small steps we've gone from snail
mail to dial up email yeah well it's
been
it's it's interesting because it's
almost similar to how
japanese games are brought over here
right right uh uh here well i'm in japan
yeah where japanese games are brought to
the west but i feel like the the whole
way the gaming industry is gone it's
like
it's like decades ahead of where the
anime is and i wonder if that's because
they kind of grew at the same time like
the culture of gaming
in america was its own thing and the
culture of and gaming in japan was its
own thing
and they kind of grew together
benefiting each other like they sent
games to each other and i wonder if
that's
if that's the reason why that industry
went so fast and why
sometimes people can't even tell if a
game is from japan oh yeah i think it's
also because like yeah
like american games now like now they're
making games
in america and in europe whereas like i
feel the anime industry won't do that
until
we get dedicated people who are making
it in america and making it in europe
because i i guess when maybe when the
japanese businessmen in like the 80s or
90s are making video games they were
like oh yeah there's chunks of gaming in
the u.s there's going to sell our
products over there yeah
there's like oh there's no anime there
that's not let's not bother doing it i
mean i i would also say that from my
like perspective i feel like the anime
industry has always been like
in my opinion like kind of like 10 years
or so behind the gaming industry i
thought
20 something yeah 20 years
in terms of the popularity and how you
know how how big the industry is
because uh like gaming right now is
probably the most
mainstream medium entertainment medium
there is now right gamers
sorry yeah i mean i mean i mean gaming
makes more than movies now
right yeah yeah so game gaming right now
you can put micro transactions in a
[ __ ] movie
that's true that's true can't roll for
your gotcha in the middle of parasite
would you like to watch the rest of this
movie five dollars please yeah but like
i would say like within our lifetime
we've seen gaming
we've seen gamers rise up to become
the most biggest entertainment medium in
the world now right where does it always
gonna rise
it used to be usb movies now do i think
anime is going to become as big as
gaming
no but i would say that anime of right
now is also rising
it's on its way it's it's on its way
it's getting more popular but that isn't
it weird though that i feel like all the
money
that the weebs have is being siphoned
off into anime games
i bet more anime games and youtube i bet
i bet
i bet we spend way more on anime games
than they do on anime merch and
100 100 100 all the weeb stuff all the
weave money they're just going in the
[ __ ] games
it's going to the game gamers
it all comes back to the game oh yeah i
mean i i feel like
probably if if you uh if you interviewed
like the average anime fan
like not not the average anime fan the
average weeb i would say the average
person in the weeb culture
they probably spend more money on like
games
or like youtubers than they do on an
actual like anime
like a figurine or a manga or something
like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah no absolutely 100 it's it's it's
weird how that
that's just the way weebs work but
that's that's what i felt that's what i
feel we've put most of their money into
maybe like maybe it's maybe in 2020
maybe it's because there haven't been
like anime conventions or things other
things they can buy
um but i would say that the more i watch
anime
the less i buy like figurines and stuff
like that you know
do you feel like i mean you're a
hardcore jojo fan right so you
you put a lot of your money into jojo
merch but nice to jojo stock yeah yeah
but now but now you but now like you
look for like the most exclusive stuff
right you don't just buy like the
the cheap no i don't like if the
figure's under like 50 bucks i'm like
yeah yeah exactly i'm like that's
peasant stuff get that out of here
because because
those figures also cheap and also when
you realize that you start collecting a
lot of figures the one thing that
becomes more valuable than the figures
is the room they take up yeah yeah so
then you're like right now i have to
decide which figures are worthy of the
display
yeah i'm like it's starting to do that
too with like exclusive like paintings
or like like limits right
right items and stuff like that i'm sure
that sounds so [ __ ] uh
sounds so so wealthy because i'm an art
collector
but it's like you know when you do start
collecting figures and you start getting
a lot
you're like you know this five dollar
goku figure
you know i kind of can't argue it
deserve the same spot as this 200
hand sculpted rem [ __ ] like dna
engraved
you know things like not not even
figurines though but like every any time
i go to an anime convention or stuff
like that
i much rather buy [ __ ] from the artist
alley and things that independent
artists are doing because
most of the time they make cooler stuff
than the official figures most of the
time or the official merchandise it's
just like
i i i don't understand people who go to
anime conventions and they buy
buttons to me buttons buttons
are the stickers for me right like the
metallics yeah yeah
i hate buttons japan is [ __ ] obsessed
with
yeah yeah why whenever i go to like a
pop-up shop for
like you you hear you hear an
announcement where oh there's a pop-up
shop for like
x anime series or why anime series i
remember the first few times i thought
wow cool they got exclusive merch there
and it's like 90 of them
are just buttons and to me like buttons
are the merch you buy when you don't
when you can't commit to buying an
actual merchandise
that's that's that's what that's like
changing yeah
it's like the equivalent of you know
when you go abroad and you're like oh
i guess i gotta buy a souvenir right
yeah you go to paris and you go
you go like i guess i gotta buy like a
[ __ ] eiffel tower key ring
it's literally the equivalent of like i
was here yeah it's like i was at that
pop-up store here is physical proof
i was at that pop-up store a 500 yen
shitty like can you
like tin can things yeah but then they
get your fight so you can't even buy the
one you want yeah
yeah you buy like 500 [ __ ] buttons
until you get the one you want
there are people though that i see that
have you know like all the whole bags
their entire bag or their entire like uh
denim jacket or whatever it's just like
covered in them and they just they sound
like a [ __ ] festival
why would you put a bunch of barnacles
on your clothes as far as i'm concerned
right
that's right that's what it looks like
it looks like it looks ugly
it's ugly and i won't stand firm people
like it man yeah i don't know what to
say
one thing one thing about the jojo event
though that i i wish that
i wish that anime did have more of these
kinds of events because i would say like
one thing that always makes me jealous
as an anime fan
from watching you know the gaming
community is that
having this live event where they have
like a load of things announced at once
right
like i've always been you on e3 of anime
i kind of do
i would love the presentations like
honestly check this out
honestly half the fun of e3 it's just
feeling like it's it's just like
what feeling like you're part of a
community and just watching it and just
reacting to it right
because like because like to me like the
closest thing anime has it's like the
anime awards right but we don't really
have any
what this is the mental image i thought
of just some guy coming up
like guys i'm proud to announce incest
the anime me and me at the team but
incest anime have worked really hard
this time this time in 8k
most anime i i do not want to know the
thought process as to why this came to
be and i do not want to do you want do
you want
why he thinks this 12 year old girl
should [ __ ] this 20 year old man
i don't want that i don't want to see a
presentation of that that is the last
thing i want and i hope
you are here
we hear you you guys want more sister
[ __ ] right
last time we heard that the plot got in
the way of the incest so we decided to
just go to bang bros
guys we hear you you want another easter
egg i just imagine they're like check
this out the [ __ ] pornhub [ __ ]
thing please
[Music]
no but like do you care about most of
the games that get announced that are
like any
you know you wait for that one jojo part
six announcement
you wait for i don't know what what else
i just think that we should get more
live events
to announce anime just for the hype
factor like it makes sense no no that's
that's what i miss i i want
i i like the hype factor in um that the
gaming community have you know it's i
feel like
it's it adds to this community aspect
and it adds to the fun
yeah yeah i mean japan kind of has that
already
yeah on nico nico they have this event
called suzuki
which i did the english version of at ax
last time
but um yeah it's literally like a live
event where they get a bunch of like
voice actors and hosts to
announce the next season of anime maybe
they should subtitle this
maybe you could subtitle it like imagine
how hype it would be when
like you hear like a chainsaw man
adaptation yeah you're just seeing it on
twitter right you have this event
where you're like oh it's [ __ ] you
know it's it's the next
trailer yeah yeah trailer where you're
like oh is this chainsaw man is this
like jiu-jitsu guys before those got
animated you know like
there's just play like scenes of the
anime yeah
like there are some manga series i know
people are waiting for like
imagine like one day vagabond gets
announced or some [ __ ] like that i would
lose my [ __ ] yeah you know and i i you
know i think it would be cool if anime
had this kind of event
where we just announced a bunch of new
anime getting getting adapted
why why we should do that
honestly like we're saying this idea i'm
just like no one's gonna do it
anime companies reach out to you please
yeah we'll do it
it just feels hard being an anime fan
you know [ __ ] we just
we spend we spend a [ __ ] ton of money we
get we get beat down on you know
[ __ ] man it's hard you're not japanese
this episode is sponsored by
honey we all show shop online and we've
all seen that promo code feel torn us at
the checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tour that scales the internet
for promo codes and applied to the best
ones it finds to your cart honey
supports over 30
000 stores online they range from sites
that have tech and gaming products to
popular fashion brands
and even food delivery did you know that
boys here's how it works imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
when you reach the checkout the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searched for coupons that can find
for that site
and if honey finds the working coupons
you'll watch as the prices drop
the other day gentlemen a third-party
delivery service app was not working
so i needed to go through a pizza
supplier directly
and i saved 10 bucks on a 45 meal that's
an expensive pizza but i'm glad welcome
save the money
honey has found us over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings
if you don't already have honey you can
literally be straight up missing on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast i never recommend something i
don't use get honey for free at
jointhoney.comtaste that's
trash taste back to the episode and it's
like people watching award shows right
because okay here's the thing nobody
actually watches an award show
to like see who wins or to like
congratulate the winners
we we watch it to get salty and to feel
like we're part of a conversation like a
sporting event
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is kind of like a
sporting event for
like entertainment right um i mean
that's that's why people watch you know
the anime awards the
gaming awards and also like the oscars
as well which apparently just
aired yesterday and no nobody watched at
the time of recording
at the time of recording it was i i
didn't know it aired until the day after
the oscars yeah i only knew about it
because i saw a tweet of some guy who
like
put down a list of the past 10 years
worth of like viewers
and apparently it's like the lowest in i
think ever
i think it had halfed in one year but
that's also because we didn't really
have any
big theatrical releases we didn't really
have any movies in
2020 most movies went to hbo max or
netflix or whatever and also i feel that
i i didn't realize now until this year
oh my god all those ads that these
movies uh pay for and all the uh
like the promotional tours and whatnot
really do work because i don't know
anything about movies unless they're
doing these
like promotional tours yeah yeah same
thing i don't know like what
i haven't heard i haven't heard of like
a single really big movie that came out
in 2020 obviously because
i only knew about the schneider cut
because that was like a meme because it
was fun yeah
the schneider card was probably the
biggest kind of movie and then
i was re-releasing i i think the only
movie i watched
last year not even in cinemas but like
afterwards was tenet
oh yeah in theaters that's really good i
didn't even watch that so [ __ ] good i
know
i heard so many people saying it's the
most nolan movie
you can ever imagine okay it's almost as
if uh
south park a parrot wrote a parody of a
christopher nolan film
and then they made it like do you know
what the main character is called
uh tell me he's called the protagonist
the main character is just called the
protagonist he doesn't have a name
he's called the protagonist it's like a
[ __ ] issue issue dude
the the [ __ ] even if the story is
kind of dominating this
this the like the visuals in that movie
are so [ __ ] cool yeah yeah oh yeah
it's so good yeah robert patson i
[ __ ] love i think he's an amazing
actor i will watch it oh yeah
because i feel like watching watching
tennant i was just like nolan's
obviously just given up on the script
he just has a lot of cool ideas for
visuals and the visuals were [ __ ]
cool
but like pay attention to the plots and
the characters for a second and i'm just
like
what the [ __ ] is going on right now you
know watching it in the movies was like
so exhausting it was literally that was
posing like this
so it's backwards in time okay because
it's pretty good it's really weird it
was one of those movies that i couldn't
imagine watching at home
i feel like the big screen i watched at
home broke
it took me like it took me it took me
two times to watch because the first
time i just got
really really bored in the first half in
in the first half right because the
first half is all plot right they had us
in the first yeah yeah
because like i was like i'm not
following what's going on i really don't
care about myself i sleep until robert
patterson comes on like i'm paying
attention all right what's up
he's so good i love him he's a fantastic
guy he's so [ __ ]
have you watched the lighthouse yeah
i've seen that i loved life what's
lighthouse
uh it's a movie with him and uh who's
the guy played jesus christ
um uh [ __ ] what is his name
who can forget his famous reel of ryuk
indefinite live action the famous four
lines he said in there yeah yeah
willow is a [ __ ] amazing actor and
they're both in it and they're both
going crazy it's [ __ ] amazing i won't
spoil it don't watch it
yeah it's kind of an artsy film but it's
really good it's really really good you
should watch it
how many films do you watch not many
maybe you probably go to the cinemas
though the most out of all of us though
right
yeah but i don't care what i watch at
the movies i'm just like how do you not
care about what you watch
it's just stimulus in my eyes we'll come
back to the oscars we'll talk about that
but yeah okay
because i enjoy just the experience of
the theater i
like the i like the popcorn i like the
fact yeah yeah
so i can ignore myself how often do you
watch films at home
oh never yeah because you're mostly just
like a netflix netflix
yeah because i'm like i'm the complete
opposite i only go to the cinemas if i
know there's a banger film i need to
watch
if not i'm just like i'll just watch it
at home pre rona i was going like
maybe once a week maybe once every two
weeks damn
because it was just like there was
always something on and um they would
always do reruns so i watched in japan i
watched the shawshank redemption
in cinemas and cinemas isn't that weird
why would you just not watch that at
home i just why not i never got to watch
you on the big screen let's go and have
a look
the best film of all time according to
imdb why would i not want to experience
it on the big thing it's a great film
don't give me a fantastic vlog
you can also watch i also don't feel bad
if i want to go and get more more
you know drink some popcorn i've already
seen it like 10 times yeah you know so
what you're saying is you just want the
popcorn
i i i really okay you want to eat
popcorn can you not eat popcorn at home
ah no not really i i i
legitimately don't go to the movies the
theater now because they don't sell
popcorn in their owner
i don't want to go not because there's a
pandemic
they're not saying that because of the
pandemic but if they let's say the
pandemic was still on i would very
much socially sneak some [ __ ] popcorn
i don't want i don't want to bring my
popcorn i want that
you want the overpriced [ __ ] popcorn
it's reasonably priced in japan at least
i i do not want to go i'm sure there's
someone out there who agrees i do not
want to go
to the to the [ __ ] cinema if i'm not
getting popcorn it's not it's
i just don't want it i don't think i've
ever bought popcorn in a cinema i i'll
i'll literally
legitimately go to a restaurant before
i'll be full as [ __ ] i'd be like gagging
at how full i am and i'll be like
one large popcorn please
i don't know what's going on yeah i'll
literally be dying but i'm like i do not
care i have to
what i don't understand is some people
like some some of my friends
who you know we we go to the movies or
we go to the cinema
and it's at this awkward time of like 1
or 1 30 you know
and it's just like do you eat lunch
before or do you not eat lunch before
and some people are just like
the popcorn is my lunch and i'm just
like how the [ __ ] is popcorn like
popcorn is not anything
i'm pretty sure you can't even live off
popcorn it's not it's not a meal
pressure is negative calories right
right it feels like
it when you're kind of just eating air
right yeah one time
in japan i spilled my popcorn over the
floor and i think that ruined the whole
movie for me
i think that legitimately made the movie
i don't even know i don't remember i was
just so i was literally distraught
for the first 40 minutes of the film i
was actually just so sorry don't buy
popcorn i was
genuinely when i when it fell over you
know when you're so sad about something
bad happening yeah that you just sit
there
for like 10 seconds and just let it soak
about how sad you are
you're like all around
you like you drop your phone and it
smashes you don't go like oh my god
you're like
yeah you can't just stare at her i don't
even even go to pick it up immediately
he's
kind of so overwhelmed with emotions and
sadness that you just stand there yeah
now you get that
and like that i had that i get that
feeling but not when i drop popcorn
no i i mean i i get it it's it's
whenever i drop any
kind of food item or drink item i've
just i've broken my phone before i've
broken expensive items
and there is something that just hurts
so much about dropping food or drink on
the floor
yeah no they're just there's nothing
can't be matched there's nothing
that hurts me more than buying a fresh
pint yeah and then
like just like immediately dropping it
or like a pint just falling off a tray
as you're taking it to the table
i think i'd rather drop my first born
child than my problem if i'm not
you know the baby can take a hit you
know i'm pretty sure i took a many hits
my popcorn doesn't take a hit
i can't eat that [ __ ] right now
especially if you pick that up everyone
will look at you yeah exactly yeah as
much as i would want to pick it
you know part of me is like is the top
layer of the popcorn on the floor okay
at least can i at least scoop some of it
back in
at least it's not directly touching it
it's like how much of this popcorn has
fallen out i want to say that i'm
hygienic but if i see
if if shut the [ __ ] up if if like let's
say
a bunch of nachos fell on the floor i
would be tempted to just be like no
not nachos not not just where they draw
the line i would be tempted
to be like i would be tempted to be like
the bottom layer is covering the screen
i will grab the top layer and now i
would eat that no
i would eat that like popcorn it comes
in pieces right because
popcorn you can scrape off the top like
yeah so you can scrape off the layer
let's say you could get the you could
get the bucket that you have with it i
would
maybe i would like kind of shuffle some
of the top ones back in if they were
if they were what you floated up
slightly
you know tilt it 40 degree angle and see
what i can like kind of scoot back in
from the top layer right that just for
me it's a little too wet
is way too wet it's like chilly i feel
chilly
like french fries right let's say that
all the french fries fell on the floor a
part of me would be tempted to be like
you know the top 40 percent of these
french fries perfect yeah no
because i'm gonna start grabbing okay
okay yeah okay because because one
okay so so there are two that sounds so
vile to something
there are two factors you need to
consider one what is the ground
is it like a clean cut no no no no
because if it's if it's carpet clean
carpet
is the worst carpet's the worst because
you got like all the [ __ ] and like yeah
all the dust and [ __ ] if you drop on the
street floor that's just like
that's that's that is game over you you
have to say goodbye
right there wood laminate flooring okay
okay yeah yeah okay maybe
maybe we could salvage most of this yeah
secondly
you need to consider what is the food
item that you've just dropped right
is is it liquid you know how how viscous
is this food
like like popcorn it comes in little
pieces you can just you can just like
scoop off the bottom layer and just
leave that on the floor and just
like it's it's like the safety layer you
have like the bottom layer and then a
safety layer just in case any of
anything on the second layer yeah yeah
yeah yeah
what if you drop a chocolate bar on the
floor you just like pick it up and
scrape it off
chocolate bar i do that chocolate bar
yeah honestly
it depends like it's a rinse it's a
solid piece of food right so it depends
on the floor that it's touching i treat
it like an indian escargot i just kind
of blow up like
just blow off the dust it's like yeah
it's good enough
i've got an immune system for one week
later we have the roanoke
i won't do it now but like during high
school like if i you know like dropped a
sandwich for example right like
depending on how it landed like if the
sandwich perfectly lands on the ground
yeah that bottom piece of bread rips
yeah you'll take everything else you're
tearing that piece off let's figure it
out
yeah
i'm taking everything else on top of it
yeah yeah yeah i'm not wasting food [ __ ]
that
we like that sully went from yeah oh
disgusting too wait maybe
wait maybe there's the situation i don't
want to waste food man
the point is i would rather drop my
child yeah
tldr i'm pretty sure my parents dropped
me
i'm pretty sure i'm fine right
didn't drop their child come on now this
is what this is why i
i'm terrified of holding a child i don't
think i've actually
i don't think i've in my 30 years of
being alive i don't think i've properly
held a baby
in my life i've seen people in japan
where they're on their bikes they have
the kid in the carriage behind them and
they have the kid in the backpack
yeah yeah and i'm like this is just this
is that's hard mode this is an accident
waiting to happen
like if the sketch is [ __ ] whichever
way you fall you are cushioning
oh god joke
i don't know that's why that's why i
never understand whenever you know one
of my family members has
a baby or something and then dead ass
look me in the eye and go do you want to
hold this baby and i'm just like why
would you trust
so why would you trust a literal life in
my hands
like i don't trust myself to hold that
does this thing come with a [ __ ]
instruction manual
like how do i operate this thing i
always wonder like
like i'm like how do you do you like it
like do you kind of like take it from
somebody who has many pictures of me
hold your babies i can tell you if you
take it from the bottom or like under
the arms yeah you do like this you like
kind of like rest them like this
now but like when i was like 14. who
told you how to do it
no one's ever told me how to properly
hold a total instinct
trial by fire
many babies i used to grab them i should
grab them by the temple
i think because like i i'm terrified of
it because
every single time bar none that i've
tried to hold a pet
it's trying to wriggle out and
and i'm just thinking [ __ ] if this
[ __ ] animal is trying to wriggle out
of my grasp i do not
want to hold a human life in my hands
and risk dropping a human life
they just complain yeah they're like
british people i don't think i've i
don't think i've ever seen a baby like
get held by someone and be like [ __ ] off
me
what are you doing like no all right go
go go anyway back to movies yeah what
what what were we saying
that was the overall part i feel
i feel like the oscars just can't win
right now but no matter what they do
they're gonna lose like if they if they
if they pander more to
or change the demo and focus more on
mainstream movies the movies people are
actually watching
i feel like the whole integrity of you
know the because you can't the artistic
integrity
[ __ ] give ten oscars to fast and
furious as much as
you know like for the fact that the the
fact that the um the harry potter movies
never got an oscar for anything
yeah the whole movie run i do feel as a
bit of a shame yeah because i do feel
during that time they were just kind of
shunned
the fact that they were seen as just
mainstream garbage and i genuinely think
that harry potter could have won in
certain areas especially like
you know like uh um set design well
there was so many times where harry
potter could have won an oscar i'll
never do yeah
and i feel like a lot of disdain was
built up during that period
where i mean i feel like the oscars just
has not aged well as time has gone on
because like i mean and then they got
caught up in the whole world
culture yeah actually i felt like when
you get into that debate you've just
lost
yeah you're gonna upset someone yeah
because once you get once you get into
the work culture debates
then you would you lose whatever side
you go on yeah would you ever you lose
whatever
enemies or even don't pander or even if
you say nothing you are still losing
you know and i i feel like that was the
start of really the decline of the
oscars along with just the fact that
it's all kind of the same along with the
fact that
the more years i watch the oscars or the
more years i cause i i don't even like
watch the oscars that
that often but like more years i watched
it the more years i realized man i just
don't know any of these movies
[Music]
because i think they had a few years uh
you know where there was a lot of
artsy films that were winning which you
know i'm sure they deserve them yeah but
i think
as a mainstream viewer most people don't
[ __ ] know what that is no
yeah um like what was the what was that
one movie that i
didn't there's a few there's been a
bunch of movies that have won best
picture i'm like what
oh yeah yeah like parasite was the first
movie the one best picture that i was
like
i know that movie i've seen that good
movie yeah um
but like a bunch of other years i've
been like what what
i mean i i think the problem with the
oscars for me is that
even if something wins best picture i
mean parasite was one of the only
best movie winners where i was actually
like everyone was happy
yeah everyone was happy with that that
was the first time when i saw people
actually happy like mostly unanimously
be like
yeah parasite deserves it it's a [ __ ]
great film because most of the times
when i see a best picture winner
on the oscars i watch it and i'm just
like yeah this is a
this is very much an oscar movie yeah
and i can see why it's so highly rated
but i just didn't find it that
interesting personally
this is what happens you know there's an
institution that goes on for too long
right it's got all these built up
um you know things that they've been
doing for years like the whole
like if you want to be in the oscars you
have to do a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
and and whole events for the people
doing it and yeah basically pay them pay
them out and pay them to get in con
considered for it
yeah and that whole [ __ ] is dumb that's
not how it should be done at all i don't
think any i don't think anybody wants a
system
where to be included in an award show
you have to there's a there's a
pay-to-win potentially i mean obviously
you don't pay to win but you pay to
enter which
i mean why not just make it so that the
best picture
gets nominated yeah you literally have
to like win the heart of the judge
by catering to them not by making
something good
yeah which is like kind of ask backwards
yeah i mean it says something when i
think that like
somehow you know something like the
crunchyroll anime awards is a better
system than the
oscars where they have a mix of like and
obviously if you do fan vote you can
kind of people are still salty
but right but i think having that kind
of fan vote in the
in the equation to say hey this is what
the fans are thinking yeah
just letting you know just letting you
know but also by making a fan voting
system it gets
those fans to actually watch the show no
it doesn't
no fans vote for what they watch they
don't vote for every show that they
on the list no no but what i'm saying is
like they're more inclined to actually
watch the awards show to see who won
if they vote for it i mean i'd say more
so than
also leaving it to an unknown committee
yeah yeah right to be like this is the
best film
no one can argue about it i mean let's i
don't know how many judges there are
there's quite a lot like 500 or
something yeah
i completely estimate maybe ashley can
you check how many oscar judges there
are yeah
i don't think is the exact number known
i'm not sure yeah but i think having
some form of weighting you know like
five percent by the fan or just
something like where the fans can kind
of have some form of yeah like the game
awards right
i mean the game was i feel like i don't
know the exact number but i feel like
it's like 10
is like the fan voted part that seems
good to me that
you know why not at least we know what
everyone else is thinking you know even
if
because i feel like the oscars is
everything i hate
about pretentious hollywood because it's
it's
it's putting these people is putting
this work on
like a [ __ ] pedestal yeah where an
award show should be just about like you
know celebrating what everyone loved
that came out in the year
i mean it's become like this whole other
political message and
yeah i mean it's i think that's what
happens when the weight of an oscar
becomes
what it is right yeah you can make your
career off winning an oscar right yeah
if you win one early on i imagine you're
the amount you just start charging
people for your work goes up
significantly yeah yeah so it's
understandable why it all comes in but
yeah it's just i mean that's why i've
always enjoyed other kind of award shows
like whenever ricky gervais holds uh
like host the golden globes that's just
like
that's just like rich people get roasted
4k
like i'd rather i take that any day over
the oscars
that's very good i do enjoy that yeah
because the oscars is always the same
[ __ ] it's like and now
for somebody who worked hard there have
been struggles and sacrifices but they
worked hard and won the award and it's
like great this
is like as if as if everybody is not
working yeah
you know you could put all the oscar
speeches into a learning algorithm and i
bet it will predict what the next speech
is
genuinely like it feels like it's
sometimes like you you got [ __ ] bra
because brad pitt did the
speech for best picture uh i know it's
best best uh actor i think
yeah or one of them i can't remember
which one um and you know it's like
you have brad pitt and then you give him
this napkin-esque mcdonald's
you know mcdonald's like commercial
speech and it's like
i want to get them to do something fun
yeah why not get them to do something
that will get people interested like to
actually talk like properly i don't know
just yes
just like i don't want to [ __ ] watch
a mcdonald's ad read go and ashley how
many
people are in the uh oscar committee
voting is jesus film industry
professionals
so roughly ten thousand people but then
also i do also think if there is nine
thousand uh people who are in judging
who are from the film industry
that's also kind of a problem in itself
right the people who are working in the
industry
are the ones who are deciding the votes
because what because i guarantee none of
them are like film critics or anything
like that right well they're i mean yeah
exactly that might be film critics
i mean if there's people who are working
on the films that are voting i think
that's a problem that's a bit of a
biases happening right a little bit you
know
i mean obviously you might not i don't
know what the rules are i mean i mean to
me there there is no perfect system
for like an award show right but either
way the way it is now isn't working
either way the way it is now is just not
capturing the
public's like interest interest interest
also why isn't it being live streamed
come on oscars we're in the [ __ ] 21st
century last year
how do people watch the oscars is it
pay-per-view it's it's not like ustv
it's on tv well why is it not on [ __ ]
youtube or twitch come on i want a pog
champ with the [ __ ]
could you imagine best best supporting
actor and this is [ __ ] monkey s right
before it gets announced you know
like i want that you know like best
actor shrek wins the oscar just [ __ ]
like shrek pogs in the chat like
this would be fun as [ __ ] like what are
you doing this is great this is how you
get people into it yeah
like if you could if you could do
channel point like gambling because you
could do gamble right like
i can do mods mods do this thing on my
stream right uh do this prediction
could you like imagine if you could do
that i bet so-and-so is gonna win
right when they're announcing the
nomination boom the prediction comes in
but pressure channel points you know
what i mean
i mean i feel like this is why the game
awards is just so much more fun to watch
as like a viewer than
any kind of film film award show yeah or
other kind of award show absolutely
you can still stick all the sponsors in
you can you can fluff the viewership
numbers because they'll definitely be
higher
yeah you can you can do so much more
like just to me it's like
yeah i mean it's just the whole system
of just old systems in place that
they're you know
have to answer too yeah just not
bothering to change your system
yeah um i mean to me the oscars has
always been that thing where it's just
been on in the background and people
have talked about it but i'm just like
yeah i mean what was the last time you
cared about who won moscow
i told you i don't know i remember the
last time i made it
i need to remember the last time i sat
down to watch the oscars
or anything like that where the [ __ ] do
you watch it you're not american like
yeah yeah i mean you can watch it like
back in australia
but yeah not here anymore i didn't even
know where to watch it in the uk
when was the last time you cared about a
winner because i feel like before
parasite i can't even
i can't shrek one of the best animated
pictures i think the last time
actually yeah it does track one no okay
best animated picture i i i feel like
that's uh
it's it's either going to be shrek or
it's it's going to be either disney or
trick like wake wake me when an anime
actually wins better
spirit right yeah that's the only time
that's probably the last time i cared
about that's the last time i was like
2006 or something like that i think
that's 2002 surprises
uh your name didn't win anything it got
nominated did it get nominated
it did get nominated but obviously
didn't win yeah this is so sad
imagine this pepe hands but it lost
yeah i mean like the anime anime has
always just been fluffed by the oscars
no matter what i mean
was it wasn't it that one year that boss
baby got nominated
a silent voice or something like that
i mean i think as well i heard that like
the only reason why i spirited away one
is because
like one of the head people at pixar
like really personally vouched for it
yeah i mean i mean
dub yeah yeah yeah exactly ghibli is the
only thing that's been noticed by uh
no yeah ghibli's been the only thing
that's been noticed by disney yeah well
cause they're certainly like holy [ __ ]
this is better anime than all our stuff
what the [ __ ]
what's going on oh [ __ ] these guys are
still doing 2d
that's the [ __ ] dedication right
there yeah exactly ldr nobody cares
about the oscars anymore
yeah until they livestream it and i can
i can do more live streaming
oh but then honestly honestly i'd watch
because then people would be like if
they let people like live stream it as
well and watch it live man their
favorite numbers would be massive
yeah yeah and maybe that'll get me to
watch more films as well
exactly no i do i do want to watch more
films it's been weird seeing
films released online on like hbo max
and stuff like that right yeah i think
it's it's
just reaffirmed for me that i just love
the movie theater and i love the
experience and
i hope that it never goes away no it's
great like i love going to it but it's
like
i'm not like you where i can just watch
anything like that it needs to be a
movie that i wonder if i just enjoy the
atmosphere so much that i will go and
watch
anything i i feel like there are some
movies that i
would prefer to watch in movie theaters
than others
like sorry tennis maybe actually i feel
like that would that would that would
have been cool in the movie theaters but
i i'd like any action flick i feel like
would be better
in the movie like i feel like i missed
out on something not watching
those [ __ ] car scenes in tennant
whether like [ __ ] going back in time
and zooming forward it was so good in
the theater it was
amazing
it's good just just for the visuals
because it's it's by far
one of the most visually interesting
interesting
like films i've ever seen super
interesting yeah
but yeah i mean i want to watch more
movies i i just
i just really can't watch movies at home
because i i put it on i see that [ __ ]
two hour thing
counting down i'm like oh that's a long
time
that's a long time to focus damn right
to me watch an hour and a half youtube
video right now yeah
yeah to me it's i don't know something
about a movie
and it's it's the commitment like once
i've put a movie on i'll i'll [ __ ]
watch it
but it's it's it's bringing myself to
it's willing myself to even put that
movie on in the first
place that's that i find trouble with
yeah i'm like i think to myself i'm like
all right
i can watch this movie it's like an hour
and a half but at the same time
i could also watch like three 30 minute
youtube videos
i could do that i think i prefer that i
could just watch random youtube videos
for an hour and a half yeah i don't
really care about that i could watch
like 320 second meme clips on youtube
i've been doing a lot of that recently
oh my god i mean that's because that's
all that's been coming up on my
recommended i don't know what's going on
with youtube recently but they just
stopped recommending youtube videos and
started recommending youtube's like [ __ ]
posts
yeah like twitter videos yeah legit it's
so weird if i get a recommendation
nowadays and it's like above a minute
i'm like oh this must be a [ __ ]
special video
oh okay the one we watched before we
start recording the chunk challenge
that's my that's my favorite video it's
been recommended recently it's brilliant
but it's gotten to the point now where
like even all the comment sections can
all agree on what
like everyone's everyone's got
recommended the same playlist because
everyone's
quoting the same videos even though
they're like they're quoting a different
video
on a different meme video and everyone
gets a reference even though it's not on
any kind of playlist or anything
yeah well it's like people watch two
hours of trash taste
[Music]
like no movie for me two hour of trash
taste podcast let's go
it's like oh wow okay thank you i'm
honest yeah thanks did you guys used to
watch more movies back in the day
oh 100 yeah yeah when i was like 15 i
loved it but that's when you discover
like that you can watch things
online yeah yeah which you can tell me i
can watch any movie i want
by just typing the name into google why
the [ __ ] are you for real
that was like a massive revelation in my
life i was like oh my god did you guys
do go through that
imdb top 100 movie phase oh yeah i know
top
250 movie phase yeah right you're not
you know what the first movie ever
i've watched illegally was what was the
hannah montana movie
how do you remember this i just remember
that's when i discovered that you could
watch it is that the one where it's like
the best of both worlds i think so i
don't know what it was but i remember
it's like the one which is on tour or
some [ __ ] yeah there was like a dance to
it as well yeah yeah cause i remember i
remember
that someone kept walking up and getting
up in front of the camera
for the movie i was one of those
well the way to see is the thing right
this is like the more you get older the
more you have money
the your tolerance for the the quality
so when you first when you're like 12
you watch anything
for some reason you're like people
standing up in front of the camera shaky
cam quality
no problem i'll watch it at the moment
you get like a hd
dvd you rip your like i can't go back
like would you like 480p
why isn't it shaking why is that no
artifact why is no one standing up in
front of the camera what's going on
oh my god yeah it was just i remembered
yeah to me it was always like the ripped
dvds that i
that sellers in thailand would just sell
so we have like
literal shops where you'd have like just
dvd cases
yeah they still do that now right this
episode of trash chase is sponsored by
liquid ivy when you push your body hard
or just feel run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated
making hydration a priority helps us
feel healthier on a day-to-day basis
and luckily with just one stick of
liquid iv
in 16 ounces of water you get two to
three times the amount of hydration
as plain water got i love hydration you
know sometimes i get a little hungover
and when i say sometimes i mean a lot
and what helps me get through the
hangover is liquid iv unironically i
literally drank it this weekend because
i was hungover my personal favorite
flavor is actually the lemon lime flavor
really mine's actually the passion fruit
flavor damn good choice jerry did you
also know that liquid ivy can provide
two to three times more hydration than
water alone containing five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an average
orange and as much potassium as a banana
and also healthier than sugary sports
drink no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple
made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy and soy
damn that's a lot of hydration so grab
your liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidity.com
and use code trash test at checkout
that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code
trash taste at liquidive.com thank you
very much liquid ivy for sponsoring this
episode
back to the video i mean that's probably
from the internet speeds there in
thailand right
are they fast in thailand does everyone
have access to internet in thailand um
i mean internet speeds in thailand are
like
faster than some than what i get in the
uk at least for uploads
i mean i mean yeah i mean like upload
speed in the uk sucks and most people
won't
yeah for some reason we've been really
cucked on the internet yeah like
download completely fine
but like upload you get like 20 max
isn't it like don't talk to me until you
went to a spot
20 years later it's like [ __ ] long
it's just it's just weird seeing that
like i was paying
you know um 70 a month in london
but promised 100 megabytes down and six
megabytes up
right i never got more than three up and
i never got more than 60 down
yeah did i pay 60 bucks a month for 0.3
up yeah but you live in a prison so
that's like yeah
we still have [ __ ] copper wire it's
ridiculous in like 2020 we have copper
wire like i i
know joke because when when whenever i
like lived in the uk i would be
you know i remember being a youtuber
being a youtuber you'd have to pay for
like the most expensive internet
available so i'm like okay who's
who's the most fastest internet provider
and at the time it was virgin media
[ __ ] awful yeah and the best they
they could provide
is like 20 up and when they say 20 up
it's really like
10 up in like the quieter times in the
quieter times in the day and then i i
would like
200 yeah yeah exactly right and then i
remember living in the uk and before
like
before like i had more american friends
i'd see like screenshots of people on
twitter being like
100 up 100 down and i'm just like this
is obviously photoshopped
there's no way there's no way [ __ ]
lie there's no way
there's no way people get this upload
speed on any kind of internet
it's just tragic in like places like
europe you can have
your neighbor could have like one
gigabyte upload and down and just
because the wire stops at his house you
you and you're his neighbor you won't
have it
you have copper i just i just couldn't
imagine not living in japan with this
god tier internet that never breaks
nothing of a bad happening
you say god to your internet i have [ __ ]
internet compared to you well my
internet is just like
like jesus came down and [ __ ] blessed
my router
uh are you hey you yeah what what speeds
you getting one one gig down
like 400 megabytes up yeah i'm getting
70 down 70 up at most
on wire really because yeah for some
reason my apartment's like
semi new but even then they they
apparently can only do like copper i
think or like some
already outdated someone cause i'm on
wi-fi and i get 500 500
what the [ __ ] am i on i don't know what
they gave you guys
yeah i upload like nearly like half a
terabyte of files every week
right and that would actually just be
impossible on my whole internet yeah oh
yeah absolutely so like right now it's
like oh
that video i just filmed was 150
gigabytes oh no worries it'll take four
hours to upload
yeah you know it's like whatever it's
crazy like this podcast i upload every
every day after we film it and it's like
300 gigabytes of video files
and uploads overnight while i'm sleeping
and i wake up my pc is on it's all done
while back in australia it's like 800
meg files
give it eight hours it'll be done by the
morning exactly yeah
[ __ ] tragic um but yeah i mean i
really appreciate that back to the whole
uh
watching shitty quality stuff i recently
watched chernobyl
and i wanted to watch it um you know in
high quality
because i just you can actually yeah
yeah you can buy it on youtube that's
how i watched it so you watched it yeah
yeah
i watched it on uh amazon prime and i'd
pay for every episode individually oh no
yeah i had to do that as well but this
is this is like how done i am with not
watching stuff in like high quality that
i would rather pay
i think it's like three dollars an
episode right and it offered me did you
want to pay a 1.50 for standard
definition
or for four dollars for hd i think you
should be shocked
as a company whoever is in charge of the
decision deserves to be shot right
okay i'm joking that's terrible
[Music]
that is a joke by the way this is
absolutely reasons it is a joke this is
a joke obviously i did yeah i'm just
exaggerating who who on earth is willing
to spend
like 1.50 for standard definition but
not the extra dollar
it is so scummy of these companies to do
why would you downgrade like
this is what i hate if you have a
product and then you downgrade it and
sell it on purpose like
no what what i what i wonder is like
they obviously know
no one's gonna buy the standard
definition because if you're buying if
if you're willing to buy standard
definition
then you're going to be the type of
person who's probably going to find
other ways to watch it rather than
watching standard definition right angry
yeah i was i was very much happy to pay
the
15 bucks to watch this whole series it
was really good yeah
but i just hate the fact that want to
make me pay for every episode
individually
and and i like in some weird way give me
a package deal give me something well
i think it's for the people who are like
oh i watched two episodes
i don't want to watch i mean there's
there should be some kind of package
deal for it yeah
no idea why i did this because i again i
don't know why i just can't be bothered
of doing the whole dance of
some watch something online spend two
hours trying to find a link that doesn't
give you viruses like
yeah i don't want to deal with that [ __ ]
anymore yeah like it's just it's too
stressful and
the watching movies is already hard
enough as is
i'm not i'm not doing this i'm not doing
this dancing i refuse
i think i watched borat on youtube
you're watching
because for some reason i wanted to
watch it again because i'm one of them i
don't know i think i've
never rented a movie on youtube don't it
was awful really because
for some reason when i rented it i was
like great it was only in like 480p
on youtube really is it is that because
it's an older movie no i i'm pretty sure
that bora is at least in like [ __ ]
720 or well i'd like to think
yeah like why i'm pretty sure it wasn't
in 480 i was like what is this
what is this i remember looking at this
[ __ ] did you did you rent the standard
no that was only one choice and it was
like three bucks yeah there's only one
choice standard definition and then also
i just found it really interesting that
youtube actually tells you how many
views the movie has
oh really i had like 20 on youtube
it might not have been legit in that
case no it was definitely like legit
really it was legit and it was just
weird because i was like this is so
strange
yeah i've been well i've been watching a
lot of films on youtube here in japan
because
i i find like if there's a film that's
not on netflix or something or
amazon here it's normally on japanese
youtube i don't know why it's like
like i started i started watching the
wire on youtube uh because paying for it
all huh you're paying for it all like
one by one no i'm paying like season by
season
but like it because i tried to watch the
wire in the uk and it just was not
available on like
any platform that i was subscribed to
basically if it's not on netflix and
it's not on amazon prime
i'm probably not gonna watch it right
but i feel like here in japan
youtube's like the golden child there
are so many films here on youtube and so
many tv series
that are blocked off when you're in like
western countries
so yeah if you're in japan use youtube
there's a lot on youtube feel like i'm
repaying my debts as a teen you know
what i mean just paying for all these
movies
with the standard definition i sit there
as i as i order my 300 yen bar at
sd quality 40p thinking old connor would
have would have gone online and found a
hd version today
no there you go here you go movie
billion dollar movie companies
is that his three bucks i don't have two
hours to kill
to find it i'm gonna have to deal with
this
i just don't care anymore i'm just like
i i yeah i don't know i don't
i value my time too much now i'm just so
busy now that the thought of spending 10
minutes to try to find a link
if i get to the five minute mark i'm
about to give up i'm like no i'm not
watching it yeah you've lost it
like 10 years ago it'd be like day 7 day
seven
like maybe it's my location changes vpn
to other countries to try and get a
different
google search you know what i mean like
i would do whatever it took like i
remember i tried to watch the um
the documentary about pepe and i just it
was [ __ ]
i couldn't even find a place to buy it
like it was [ __ ] impossible to try
and find this movie to watch it were you
in the generation where you
where people were watching things on
mega uploads yeah oh yeah yeah
do you remember do you remember the
dance you had to do with the 72 minutes
time limit so for anyone too young to
know yeah
so for anyone too young to know there
used to be this site called mega upload
right
where people would upload you know full
tv series and
four movies on it yeah now most movies
they're on time it's normally like at
least an hour and a half
right like 100 minutes yeah yeah like
like 100 like 100 minutes
so mega upload for free account had a
time limit
of 72 minutes and for every 72 minutes
you watch
you had to wait 72 minutes to watch the
to to watch it again right such a dick
move yet
amazing marketing choice oh my god it
was such a dick
like i don't know why like was it
because it was the only site that was
available it was one of the only file
sites that was like
welcome everything you want
yeah and i remember back in the day when
because this was when i was in
university
so i i think back back when mega upload
was popular i don't think vpns were as
popular right because vpn's
vpn would be like the easy answer to
this nowadays right
and i remember feeling like i was like
so [ __ ] five heads
where where
what i would do is our university had
like a private network that we would
connect to to upload like our files or
upload our projects and stuff like that
all right um and so what i would do is i
would watch the 72 minutes then i would
connect
to the to the uh to the university
internet and start uploading on there
was like the eduroam
huh eduroam something like that right
and then that worked great until i did
something stupid
i started blabbing in my mouth about it
so unfortunately
i lived in a shared house so
so this 72 minutes the 72 minute limit
became like five minutes where everyone
in our house started watching mega
uploads and you
used like the same network and use the
same same ideas
and uh yeah that was and then i realized
it's just much better to live by
yourself
and just not have to deal with people
sharing your internet do you remember
having to remember trying to game
online on university internet and how
[ __ ] awful that was
terrible yeah it says there's a memory i
don't want to think about it
yeah i have like flashbacks of just the
ping going from 10 to like 500.
who's loading porn i mean it wasn't even
that bad for me because like because of
australian internet our default ping was
like 300.
so it was more like going from like
three hundred yeah yeah like nine
hundred game in the show and they were
like yeah
i've got great ping oh what is it off
300 i'm like that's that's not
no measurement is that a good thing if
you have below 250 you're like damn this
guy's paying for like the premium
internet
i don't know i i i i feel that uh
university internet was just the most
temperamental thing ever yeah but it's
really cool because i remember
that uh because a lot of them use the
eduroam network i remember once i went
to germany and i walked past university
and i was like oh
i connect to the internet i can't see
that university's internet right because
i was or they
shared the same uh id for like wi-fi or
something or something like that right
but if i walked past any university you
get free wi-fi when you're a university
student wow
if it was using the same network which
most of them were i think in europe
it's really cool fun fact wow life hack
yeah life hack just
i don't know do something walk past you
guys just get free wifi just get free
wi-fi
stop complaining it's free actually i
have a really awkward story about when i
set up the wi-fi here in japan um
because um yeah obviously obviously you
know we just moved to japan
and one of the hardest things especially
when we moved here was [ __ ] setting
everything up initially yeah he knows
all too well joey knows all too well
kind of moved here like two weeks before
me so joe
can't have the cheat sheet or just
having joey set up everything for him i
was like i wanted to get in first with
joey
i
when you ask joey like to help you set
up i could see like just the hope
just wash over his face and be like oh
this is the last time conor this is the
last time and
i remember when you were talking about
setting up like your driver's license
and like i could see joey's just like no
don't ask me connor no i'm not i'm not
going to do it
yeah i mean that i feel bad yeah luckily
there was someone else who i hadn't
bothered yet
so yeah so as i was setting up the
internet as as you know i have like
really really slow internet compared to
you guys
right um and i'm kissing
a peasant internet um i can't remember
who i'm with it's not a you
it's the other software
no it's not it doesn't matter but they
have to do something right yeah they
they have like
english support which is why i picked
them right because i had to try and sort
this out by myself
um so when they said they have english
support
it's it's the most it's it's basically
just like here's the person who
translates using google translate
japanese companies are like english
support or for foreigners only
95 of the time it's just someone who
doesn't really speak good english and
just a way for them to hike up the price
oh yeah yeah like if you go to the like
uh like what is it like gaijin
is that what it's called yeah like that
that real estate website if you go and
find the same properties on a japanese
website they're much cheaper
yeah it's just like it's like thirty
percent cheaper it was just like ah
it's like okay it's been taking
advantage of because uh you know
they do do that just ask someone who's
japanese to help you you'll save a [ __ ]
ton of money
you might lose a friend yeah at least
you'll have saved her just make a
japanese friend
to eventually lose said pay him the
money that you saved
honestly there should be a service for
someone to help you because that would
have that that could save you a lot of
money a service hire a japanese who
speaks english
to come with you to stuff basically i
pay that's my first really right this
way
like the reason i was able to set up my
phone was because luckily
my cousin was here at the time and i
asked i asked her to do it and she works
for jael so she can speak you know
pretty fluent japanese and she helped me
set up
perfect no bumpy roads setting up the
internet what's up
[ __ ] nightmare on my phone so i'll
tell mine after yours go
okay because like firstly you firstly
like you have to
sit up with the internet provider and
then also set it up with
something else as well um i didn't have
to do that for mine you didn't you
didn't have to do that because i i i
like i get billed from two companies and
i don't
exactly understand
[Music]
google translate as no scam
soft tech support they were very nice
they assured me
that it might work it was an indian guy
on the phone they assured me
through google play cards you know it's
totally legit
[Music]
no but from what i understand you have
to set up with like the is the person
who provides the isp
and then i think and then the guy i
think because i think au provides both
services
whereas my my company did not provide
both services at once i think yours is
like
yahoo mobile or something right where
it's like it's probably like
it's probably like a version of like
yahoo or something like that because i
remember i had that and i
had to do something similar yeah because
the person that provides the line and
the person that like
installs the router and rents out the
router and stuff for you is like two
separate repairs
out the route they're like [ __ ] 40
bucks yeah i know no no but the thing is
you can rent one out
and have them set up for you or you can
set up yourself
and so i i chose no with the internet
option i had
i didn't even have that option because i
would have loved just to rent out a
router and have the engineer
set up no i wasted a day trying to
figure out how to set up my [ __ ]
router
and you know connect it to the isp in
japanese and japanese menus and
everything it was it was a [ __ ] hell
but
before that i had to even just set up
the deal that i was getting right
and so i phone up and i'm just like okay
yeah i'm living here um
i i choose the english option and even
then
it's it's like it's rough it's it's a
[ __ ] rough kind of kind of like it
took me
i think an hour of an hour of an hour
phone call to communicate
10 minutes worth of stuff and just to
make sure that everything was correct
and
i tell them all my details and so we're
going through it
and then they they tell me that we're
sorry
um this is the fastest internet you can
get at this house
uh at this apartment and i'm just like
that's
like your lowest option that you have on
your website because they have like they
have like different tiers
right they have they have like the high
paying option and they have like the
[ __ ] peasant option as they always as
they
always do i know like we're sorry you
can only get the peasant option
and i was like asking why right and they
will say they told me
that um sorry your building is not new
enough
and it doesn't have the newest internet
installed yeah that's the problem with
japanese
internet is that like depending on the
building and the why's built into it
yeah they're just like we can't do it
sorry yeah
so ridiculous so i was like there's no
way that this is true because
my apartment's pretty modern it's it's
it's like it's it's i think it was
built it's new it's nearer than mine
yeah it's much new it's newer than your
one and i i heard about the speech you
were getting so i was like
i was like i was like where's this
phantom speed going
yeah yeah yeah i was like doubts right
you're stealing the the next door
building
yeah yeah so so so like so like i'm just
like
let me consider this deal right so i am
so i hang up i phone up the next day
and so i could talk to someone different
right so i can just
make sure that uh it wasn't just that
it wasn't just that person i was
miscommunicating to right um so i phone
up i
go through the same [ __ ] hour phone
call that doing it again
explaining yes uh i just want to make
sure
that this is the best option i can go
for
this is the best option and there isn't
a higher option
and and the second person i was talking
to goes
hold on a second let me just talk to my
manager and so
she gets her manager and uh her manager
comes on
it's the same [ __ ] guy i talked to
yesterday
and so i was just like yeah uh can i
just
make sure that this is the highest
option available
and he goes you're the guy that phoned
yesterday
aren't you and i was like yeah this is
this is this is awkward um can i just
double double make sure and he was like
yeah i mean i just
made sure again uh it's the best option
available and um
this is smaller i wonder i wonder if you
tried a different internet company yeah
i wanted to and so i go i go through the
ordeal again
and i you know give them all my details
again and this time i actually
have to send my send my id or scan my id
just to make sure everything's all
everything's all kosher [ __ ] you're not
first bill i get
right i open up grant manny tapo
[Music]
i sent him my id so that they can verify
my name and address
and they get
i think the visa people just spilled
wrong [ __ ] the pizza people
yeah i mean like so i bought the [ __ ]
internet turns out it was [ __ ] yeah
so yeah i mean i couldn't be bothered to
[ __ ] go through another like two hour
phone call with another company
and i just settled for it and uh i mean
trust me like even if you were perfect
in japanese it probably would have taken
just as long
like because my god reaction when jerry
helped me try to get my uh
internet and sim card and originally i
got internet and uh a sim card with the
same company yeah um turned out the sim
card just didn't work on my phone
yeah and uh because they were like oh we
don't sell this model of phone in japan
um so in in europe i don't know if it's
the same as the u.s
but you can basically buy sim cards
anywhere and they'll work with every
phone yeah like it doesn't matter what
it is you just put it in it works
yeah um but yeah apparently that's not
the case in japan because of course it
isn't
found out that japan is the only country
on earth that uses a very specific type
of uh
like uh bandwidth or whatever it is that
the phone lines use
so a lot of phones don't work in japan
because japan was like no no we're gonna
be different and it's like
of course you watch man yeah of course
everything's got to be different
and that's why like getting a phone here
is [ __ ] hell yeah and that's why like
sim cards are so expensive i think
recently they did something about
uh they're gonna change it because i
think the government is like it's
getting out of hand
like the prices of phone phone carriers
here ridiculous i mean i'm paying more
for my phone than i am my internet
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm paying 90 bucks
a month for my [ __ ] phone yeah and
that's
that doesn't include that doesn't
include the phone that's
i bought the phone myself i think i'm
paying like 70 bucks a month and when i
get like it's
in gigs of data yeah it's insane it's
like what is this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is stupid this is way too much
for a [ __ ] it's okay it's good but
i mean it's good it's good but it's [ __ ]
but it's [ __ ] that they're charging me
this much yeah i paid
i paid 15 in the uk for what i was 10
pounds
for what i was getting yeah i i think i
paid like 20 pounds a month in the uk
that's expensive for like unlimited data
yeah it's ridiculous
and when in the uk when they when they
say unlimited data they actually mean
unlimited data i've never been throttled
in my data in the uk at all the speeds
are fantastic here don't get me wrong
but speeds are great not not to the
point where we're talking a hundred
dollars a month
speed come on yeah yeah it's more than
my internet bill you're having a bit
come on
yeah it's a joke i mean it works really
well but i just yeah
and that's why like a lot of people i
know don't even bother getting sim cards
because you have to sit there for like
four hours
talking to them asking answering dumb
questions and they try and sell you a
ton of stuff like uh because i think aki
doesn't even use her
no she still has an american thing and
just pays for
wi-fi because she's like she looked at
like all of her friends getting
you know the sim cards and whatnot she's
like i'm not going through that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that it's hell but i just don't
want to have to charge a [ __ ] uh
portable wi-fi thing all the time oh
yeah yeah
having a japanese number does help
sometimes with things like a lot of
forms
require you to have japanese numbers for
some reason yeah she just uses yeah
where's my japanese [ __ ] fluent
boyfriend who translates and does
everything for me huh
yeah no so if i were her i would totally
do the same thing yeah to be honest yeah
honestly like the only reason i wanted a
phone was because i didn't want to carry
an extra thing with my phone just to get
one
right you're not carrying like a person
with you all the time yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah um but yeah i know several
people who just have pocket wi-fi here
just because it's
they don't want to go through the
trouble of switching their phones or
well i mean rainer still has pocket
wi-fi she's been living here for like
however many insane do you even have
pocket wifi isn't popular in like europe
i don't think in
the us it's like not mainstream i never
really heard of it it exists but like
it's
it's not like it's not nearly common as
you see here because clearly they've
made a market where
the phone the cell phone carriers are so
[ __ ] awful that there's a
whole industry about avoiding them yeah
look
it it's ridiculous and the price of
these pocket wi-fi's are much cheaper
than the south
cheaper yeah it's just stupid yeah like
i legitimately dread whenever i have to
sort out like the smallest thing
within like my living situation here in
japan because like if they they
i don't know how they all somehow always
turn like a five to fifteen minute
meeting to like
a [ __ ] hour long now
i'm waiting for the day where you know
how sometimes when you're on a website
you have to change your email
they'll be like please come in person to
change your email and everything like
four hours and it's like i could have
done this online
okay [ __ ] japanese banks man i
i'm i'm about to go [ __ ] mad like
okay so
oh god he broke the flashlight
honest honestly japanese banks do you
want to preface before we get into this
we do love living in japan very kind
country we do
very great and everything i can we are
everything in the uk
i'm an innocent bystander in this case
oh [ __ ] like you don't complain
about the banks we complain about
everywhere we live
um and especially if something like is
inefficient
to to a brit you know we will happily
wait in line but if if that meeting
takes any seconds longer than it needs
to we are we are going to complain the
[ __ ] about that
so so japanese banks we have to [ __ ]
since our visa only lasts six months
we have to we have to go to the bank
every time to tell them not to cancel
our card
right and the thing about japanese banks
is that you can do
[ __ ] nothing on the phone right
so just just so they don't cancel a card
every time our visa runs out every time
we renew our visa we have to go there
in person and not just any branch of our
bank we have to go to
the branch that you start we have to go
to that specific branch which if you
don't live anywhere near the branch you
open your bank account you're pretty
much [ __ ] yeah yeah they didn't give
me a warning they didn't tell you what
yeah
so you could be like stranded in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere in japan and
not be able to get any money out
yeah because they've blocked they've
cancelled your card and not told you
yeah and
another thing is i needed to go there
for like uh i needed
a bank statement right you you think for
a bank statement that's a
pretty no on the app go online that's a
pretty normal document
you can obtain from a bank correct so i
go to
the i go to the bank and i ask for a
bank statement
and they have like [ __ ] 70 million
different kinds of bank statements and
i'm just like
what's how hard is it tommy money go in
money go out money go and money go out
what what is the document where you can
see money go in
money go out transactions you spend
money here
i just need that document and they're
like
okay maybe we can do that maybe maybe
maybe let's let's see they go they go
they go away they're talking to the
manager yeah
literally literally go where they talk
to the manager they give me like two
forms to fill out
and go and go um so are you okay getting
this
in three weeks um i'm like is there
any faster way to get this documented
like no if you if you want this document
because you didn't sign up for it before
you have to wait three weeks and we'll
send it to you
now do you want this document monthly or
do you want us to like just hold it and
then i'm like no
now from now on give me this monthly
because there is no other way to obtain
a statement if
unless you just go to the bank and ask
for it and you have to ask for this
option
when you sign up for a bank account or
when you when you realize that you need
a bank statement for
whatever you know what is the point of
like the 900
printers that they have like what are
you using these printers for
and so on and so i'm waiting for this
document
for like for like you know because i
needed to file some stuff i needed a
bank statement
took five weeks for it to get sent i
didn't realize when i said three weeks
they went three
like three three minimum yeah three
weeks minimum
yeah basically uh japanese banks i don't
know if we've just been really blessed
with uk banks
but in the uk the apps work amazingly
the apps work amazingly you can just
transfer money
on an app it's pretty it's pretty secure
and i can have my statements if i i have
like
three to four no [ __ ] five years
worth of like bank statements that i can
have
done pdf do whatever i want now japan
has those as well like i use a bank
currently that has a great [ __ ] app
and i can do transactions all on my
phone the problem is
they're not the major banks all of the
major banks are like
you have to go in in person bring your
[ __ ] stamp
and sign like 17 pieces of paper we'll
send you something in
two years yeah because i've wanted to
transfer money back to my uk account for
like since
since i moved here um i just don't i'm
just dreading the ordeal i have to go
through just just to just so i can move
money from one place
it's like a whole day event it is it
[ __ ] well it should be five minutes
long
like every gu every time i go to the
bank i lose at least an hour or two of
my life yeah it's unfortunate that like
things that should take 10 minutes or 15
minutes tops always like four hours in
japan
i think that that's where the
frustration comes from where it's like
you put middlemen and checks
in places where there didn't need to be
yeah any you know
anything it's like why do you have to
ask your manager if everything dude
needs a bank statement everything
anything you do they will always ask the
manager it's like do
any of your employees have the ability
to do anything on their own are your
employees like trained
at all like just just make a [ __ ]
decision for yourself
yeah jesus what are you employed for
yeah i mean like by the time i got the
statement the statement was like already
out of
date because it was a month old
statement right
so i had branches i had to [ __ ] i i i
like [ __ ]
begged um because because i was filling
out tax stuff and i was i was [ __ ]
begging my accountant to be like
please let this be like please please
let this be usable because i don't
want to [ __ ] do this again i don't
want to go through this ordeal again i
want to wait five weeks ago
i think the most frustrating part about
it is that when you're like please help
me with this thing they make you seem
like you're the weird one for like
wanting to like
make stuff go quicker or do things
simpler they're always like why would
you want to do that
yeah this is the way we do it yeah this
is this is the this is the
way that where it's a hundred percent
success rate so it's like why else would
you make it
any other way well i remember because i
think i think dogen
uh did a video about the japanese banks
as well and he mentioned something else
one time where he was like sometimes you
just have to tell them like no
like yeah just tell them no that's not
gonna work
and then maybe be like you have to do
this or help me do this
and the manager might be like okay but
it's sad isn't it that
sometimes you have to put your foot down
to get anything done here yeah
it's just terrible it's just so sad it's
that you have to like pull tooth and
nail to get the best service
that they offer right yeah which is why
i hate
sometimes i feel bad when i uh ask
japanese people to help me with it
because if i'm like can you ask them to
do this like no no
they don't do that here it's like if
you're a foreigner friend they'll at
least ask they'll be like hey can we do
this but if i'm asking a japanese friend
to help me
like who's 100 japanese you know right
that you know is fluent in english
somewhat
hey can you ask them this they'll just
they won't even ask cause i'll be like
no no you can't ask them that yeah i
mean look at your desk just ask
and try you know you know like yeah
japanese way of thinking yeah right
because they don't want to like
embarrass themselves they don't want to
ask questions
that they feel they already know the
answer to because they feel like that's
like humiliating at times uh whereas i
think i always just
of the mindset of there's no harm in
asking yeah right i mean like i i
never thought i would go to a place
where it's like it's like a 50 50 on
whether you'd be able to get
a [ __ ] credit or debit card right
i got rejected for all my cards uh in
the start yeah yeah exactly i had to
apply two no three two or three times
until i finally got a debit card
really yeah um [ __ ] help yeah so it
was like the worst one
so so yeah he so in japan right when
whenever you sign up to a bank account
in most countries that i know
you get a [ __ ] debit oh yeah you do
this yeah so yeah yeah yeah so so in
most other countries you get a debit
card in which
you can spend your money which you put
in your bank
in japan they're like we do not do that
here we don't want you spending your
money
we'll give you a bank card they will
give you a cash card
in which you can take out money at the
atm and also charge you a fee for taking
money out of the atm
so when you go to when you go to the atm
and get money out
you you better be taking a large amount
of money out otherwise you'd just be
like
[ __ ] for fees um oh by the way you
can't pay with anything with the cash
card this cash card can only be used to
take out cash from atms yes you also
can't take out any money with your debit
card
debit card can only be used to pay with
things yes of which
if you apply for a debit card you have
the possibility of being
rejected yeah like why why
like i like credit cards i understand
credit card because it's like you know
you're using their money yeah but like
for like most countries i know like
[ __ ] america they give out credit
cards like they give out free candy you
know like they're in the uk
same in the uk you're like because they
want you to get in debt so they can
make your life happen for all the money
it's like you have do you have a pulse
brilliant here's a 2 000
here's a 2000 pound
all the credit card companies make all
their money off the people who are
failing to pay back their credit cards
like that's where they make all their
money yeah in japan it's just like
oh you want to pay for stuff not using
cash
i don't know what i don't know about
that one chief it's like i
you know if i'm paying for like my rent
or something or i'm paying i don't want
to pay in cash
why are you making me paying cash a
thousand dollars don't make me don't
make me carry a thousand dollars around
i don't want to do that after paying the
atm fee yeah yeah so like i tried to buy
a new camera
and my card my debit card had a limit on
it i didn't know that
how do i change the limit i've got to
[ __ ] call them up haven't i offered
of course yeah
there's not an app or anything i got to
do i got to call them up explain it like
why would you want to increase the limit
none of your [ __ ] business why i want
to create it's my money i want to use it
what do you mean
yeah it's it's it's it's like now that
i've lived here for
like one and a half years i've realized
that it would be
more convenient for me to use my foreign
card here
than it would have been to like set
everything up because like the fees
that they charge you whenever you take
money out is exactly the same like
it's about the same fees that you use
sometimes
sometimes yeah the only real difference
i feel is like the exchange rate you
know that that obviously goes up you're
[ __ ] by the exchange rates that's why
i
always that's why i wanted the debit
card because i was like losing a lot of
money because i was i was having to use
my my british card and i was just losing
money on exchange because the pound's so
strong compared to the energy well yeah
as well like right now i want to use as
much yen as possible because the rest of
my money's in pounds and it's really
strong and i don't want to use that i
want to get rid of the weak money that i
have right like spend it all spending
like
but like in in that case it would be
like it's way more convenient to use
like a third-party company like revolut
or like transfer wires like get it
because you can actually get like a
physical card where you put money into
this account well yeah i used to have
one
yeah yeah exactly but when the uk left
the eu i lost that card and yeah you
stopped ranking oh [ __ ] in the uk so
the one good card i had that was perfect
for transferring uh
for using foreign exchange was just
useless after a while
yeah look at us talking like adults
about their credit cards and
banks well it's just sad because they've
they've made a system that makes it hell
at every turn and
yeah you need to answer for every like
little things
that you just like comfort or like yeah
you have to explain why you want them
yeah and it's like
that i shouldn't have to explain to you
why i want to up the limit on my card
like that that should be a myth why do i
have to tell you like
i'm getting interrogated because i want
to buy a [ __ ] camera like what is
this
this is i don't like this i i i not that
i i don't mind telling that i'm like
yeah it's for a camera but the fact that
i have to
answer to you like like what like if
it's for like a a couch that you don't
like you'll say no [ __ ] you
ugly ass catch [ __ ] that yo let me check
this out hill really really the thread
count on those shoes
suck bro i'm not going i'm not up in the
comments
why are you asking me this is there is
there a situation where you like i'm
going to launder more money
well then of course you're going to say
no because i'm doing something illegal
when why is this ever gonna work like
what is this point of this question
don't ask me this [ __ ] you know make a
conversation if so [ __ ] stop
yeah you know meanwhile like uk banks
but i just got the text
the other day being like weaved up the
limit on your credit card and i'm just
like
well i didn't ask but i guess
oh cheers cheers but uk bank's always
really good they update me all the time
you know the app's fantastic i can
transfer money to anyone
no no questions asked yeah well i mean
like [ __ ] bank apps are like
i think only maybe like a thing that was
invented two or three years ago here
when i first moved here like none of the
banks did you have online banking when
you moved here no
literally i and i still don't have it
here because it's a because it's [ __ ]
horrible i don't know
how to transfer money online in japan i
still haven't figured it out
i don't know well i mean some banks
don't even let you do it i i don't even
know if it's possible
right yeah all i know is that somehow
when i have you been able to log into
your
online banking i've logged in so the the
online banking that i have
to send money is like i okay i have
logged into my bank but if i want to
send money it's through like a different
it's for my card
it's really again this whole [ __ ] it's
been separated
you don't understand what's going on it
doesn't make any sense japanese banks
suck
please please this is why if you're a
tourist you got a lucky man you have to
deal with this stuff that's why everyone
says japan is the best place to visit
worst place place to live but it's it's
an amazing place it's an amazing place
there's just a lot of things that i took
for granted that i thought were just
little conveniences
or just just the way the world works in
first world countries
you get mega angry and then you go
outside you go to matsuya and you get
your mats here yeah like nice
all right there's always a lot of
distractions it's all it's all worth it
but for that one day where you're
dealing with this stuff you're like i'm
finna book a flight
wrong yeah i'm getting real tired no
because it's not just about it because
i've lived in thailand as well and even
they've got their banking system
more convenient than they do and i've
got i have an app
i can transfer my money in my thai bank
account to my japanese bank account if i
wanted to i can't do that in japan
and japan's a first world country
thailand's like a second world country
when i left the uk closing everything
and getting everything all sorted moving
everything i need to do i did
everything in like half a day just
making phone calls just being like hey
can i do this
i'm leaving and they're like oh yeah
totally fine yeah okay yeah oh hey
can i do blah blah blah yeah it's all
good or all every phone call lasted like
at most
the whole the being on hold took longer
than the phone call yeah it was like
it's so easy like it's it's so
frustrating whereas here it's like
oh you're moving oh yeah you're moving
that's a whole month process yeah that's
not because you've got to unpack and
move stuff around that's because you've
got to go to this you've got to call up
and go to [ __ ]
in store everywhere it's ridiculous so
absurd so
again we complain a lot about these
aspects of japan but
you know we are very grateful to japan
for allowing us to be here i mean
there's a reason why you're
still here yeah we love it you know i
mean we're probably gonna stay here i'm
gonna be living in japan for a long time
yeah yeah i just you know i think that
uh when you live in a place
you have the right to complain about
certain things absolutely i complain
about
everywhere equally you everywhere sucks
everywhere sucks exactly there's no
utopian country yeah
exactly and so we you know i i i i don't
want people to get the idea that
we're not [ __ ] grateful or we're not
like yeah because we get something
like that yeah we do get comments later
sometimes and we are very happy here in
japan we're just being real with you
guys
we just we just like to complain about
the little things yeah and you guys like
it when we're annoyed about [ __ ]
that's why we're annoyed about it if you
guys are gonna move japan i want i want
to be honest with you and tell you
what's going to be fun and what's going
to sell yeah there's going to be there's
going to be lots of [ __ ] great things
about it but just be prepared for those
inconveniences whenever you have to do
anything to do with like japanese
bureaucracy or just setting
setting up your living situation yeah i
i you will be writing your name address
and phone number more times than you'll
ever think you all lose at least a week
just checking yeah i think i think
that's the thing that annoys me in the
uk when i had to deal with this stuff it
was
it was maybe an hour out of my day at
most and i get on my day
if it happens here it derails your whole
week like it takes it completely
you have to reschedule everything cancel
everything you're doing because
you've got a call from the bank they
said that your card's cancelled and they
didn't tell you
i just remembered like i don't know if
you guys have in the uk but like
in japanese and australian airports
there's like sometimes that service
where like you know how
on your suitcase you can pull like a
belt so it doesn't burst open
some people forget that or you know
don't buy that so instead you can like
you can use a service that you can like
wrap up your bag and like i said
yeah yeah yeah in australia it's like 10
seconds you just like wrap this up
here's the money they do it all right
see you later
i did it in hanada once in japan and
they were like okay can you fill out
this form
uh write your name oh address and phone
number i'm like
i'm never gonna see you again just wrap
up my god damn
get the [ __ ] cling film out wrap it
around and i'll give you 20 bucks
i looked at this woman i was like what
do you need this for like why do you
need to know my name phone number and
address and they're like oh you know
like just in case i'm like
i guess you're wrapping my bag in
plastic i'm a customer
i i will do it myself give me the give
me the give me the clean
i'll [ __ ] blow myself right now i
will pay you
to not fill it that way it was
ridiculous it's frustrating man and i
just wasted like you know two minutes of
my life filling out this form that
for one i don't even know what they're
gonna use it for but second of all
completely unnecessary
frustrating giving out your whole
[ __ ] information to
[ __ ] that you feel like it just totally
doesn't need it right yeah like i just
don't want to deal with that i hate
doing that but it's also like you know
i feel as well like there's so many
situations where you're
canceling something or you know you're
upgrading something right and you're
just like all right can you write your
phone number and azure so i'm like
i'm pretty sure all my information is on
the system just look it up
i'll give you my [ __ ] name i'll let
you know yeah i'll keep you like how
often do you think i'm changing my name
and address like one one thing i'm
[ __ ] dreading
when we move because we're all planning
to move from where we are now i mean
you're already in the process of moving
yeah um is just the process of changing
my address
in every bill that i've had and
i'm just i i i wake up in a cold sweat
at night sometimes being like
i gotta do that i haven't been suffering
for the past month on that
and it shouldn't be a suffering it just
sucks because i feel like just life just
comes to a halt for a month because
they've designed systems that make it so
yeah and it's got nothing to do with
like you know
people who don't understand the language
having a hard time no
even if you're fully japanese it's still
hard as [ __ ] to do and it shouldn't be
that hard
like you get pretty good customer
service in most aspects of
a japanese life i think but this for
some reason with uh
personal information companies feel like
it comes to a whole and it doesn't
it doesn't improve at all like the
customer service isn't any better for it
uh i think that's why i think japan has
one of the lowest productivities
out of yeah of first world countries i'm
not surprised uh
because they work the most we would have
flying cars by now
they work more hours than any other
country and have less to show for it
yeah you know what i mean like
you know i think in some european
countries they're considering a four-day
work week even
and you know which is like that's
fantastic you bring that up to
government officials in japan they're
like
how does that how does that country run
how is that not a third how is it a
third world country
how is their economy not crippled to the
ground because again just like
how do you fix it when everything in
society has been made to be
long-winded bloated and slow like what
do you do
like how do you fix that because it's
like a whole cultural thing this is a
country where a lot of schools
are still six days a week yeah i mean
it's ridiculous a little like four-day
work week what yeah i mean it took like
a [ __ ]
global pandemic right for the country to
embrace
working from home and online meetings
right
they were like they were throwing out
like the buzzword of like
home workstation or whatever the [ __ ] it
was like like it was a new thing that
was just invented
like we've come up with this
revolutionary thing get this
you can work from home and japanese
people are like impossible
that is that's again
they call it telework like also i think
i think they're now
slowly starting to face out the hanko
because of it but they're finally
putting in like the government they're
bringing it up and trying to explain
huncles i don't think we have hunk
hunker basically
is like the it's like a stamp
essentially that has your surname on it
or
you know company name or whatever
basically it's the japanese equivalent
of a signature yeah but
incredibly tedious it's incredibly
tedious because that means you have to
carry your hanko
everywhere yeah whenever you're like if
if you forget
you're hungry if i find moments where
i'm like i have everything
except the hunger and they just don't
accept it yeah and i'm just like
this is a stamp i bought a donkey hotel
for like 200 yards
like the dollar shop here yeah you can
you can just get it at a dollar shop
imagine your name is connor
right and then you know you you got
those gift shops and they have like the
license plates like connor yeah
it's like that like imagine you just go
to the store you find your name on the
license plate and then you bring it and
go look it's my name
and it's my name look take a picture the
thing is is like i i've read up a thing
as to why japan still uses the honker
and not signatures
and the most accepted like excuse i
guess i'm going to just go and call this
game as why they don't use signatures
they were like well anyone can copy a
signature anyone can go to donkey hot
air
and buy a two dollar stamp what are you
on
it's yeah it's so dumb yeah i mean if
you have a popular name
yeah like yeah what happens if you have
a popular name yeah right what is it uh
what is it
what's the one you always see tanaka is
that the one yeah like subtle like any
of like
probably has the same [ __ ] don
quixote stamp yeah so i'm like
there's [ __ ] like it's signature is
way harder to copy than buying a stamp
like did you hear about the [ __ ] josh
battle royale that happened recently
did you hear about this song
so like i think like a year ago some guy
in like some state or something he
looked up
every he was his josh
he looked up like every josh on facebook
in his area
and added them to a group right and he
just sends a message
guys you know why we're here we're going
to battle for the name josh
they're are only josh's here we are
going to have a battle royale
and whoever's whoever emerges victorious
can keep the name josh
so that's how it works with hankers
there's literally
i feel like they have to do that with
hong kong there's literally a [ __ ]
battle royale movie in japan
where it's that exact same concept is it
really yeah yeah it's called it's called
real tag where basically it's it's like
a survival horror movie it's actually a
really good movie and book
but basically in this it's set in like
the future where the king of japan his
name is sato which is the most
common surname in japan and he's like i
want to be the only subtle
so what he does is every night at
midnight he's like all of the subtles in
the country have you come to legend game
yeah
literally and they're like and they're
like to all satos of japan
there are too many of you so we're going
to get rid of some of you and it's like
literally a survival horror movie where
all the sato is like
running for their life not to get
[ __ ] illuminated
it's a great [ __ ] movie yeah it's
like an anime yeah it really does
it's not a great movie but it's
literally like that i'm just trying to
think is there anything in like
uk or australia that is like
unnecessarily like slow i feel like we
just kind of get rid of it
we've already complained about that i
feel like as in like the systems that we
have i don't really think there's
anything that's like everything's been
like easy to do like i mean i didn't
really have
experience living on my own right in
australia so i can't really say that
okay everything that could be done
online is done online you know yeah
i i mean yeah most i cannot even i don't
even think i
ever went anywhere in person for
anything like a government
like you could all be done by phone or
online yeah
water bill internet phone
government documents like local tax like
all of it was done online i think the
only thing really is like you know
going to get like your driver's license
fixed or something right like you
probably have to go in person
then in the uk you can you can uh get a
meltdown yeah i like when i renewed my
driver's license i
just actually just sent sent them the
license in the mail uploaded a scan of
my picture and then they just renewed it
for me okay you can't do that in
australia yeah i mean
we've really been like the uk has gotten
really good at making things that it's
sufficient
and i guess i just took that for granted
right sure did god
sure yeah yeah yeah you're like
everywhere's like this like i'm i'm like
i'm like i i thank god that we're signed
with geeks plus and they handle our
attacks
yeah because like oh god i can't imagine
i've heard horror stories i mean i did
my attacks
before joining geeksplas and it was the
[ __ ] worst
if you are a freelancer in japan good
luck i've heard that i mean i mean
freelance tax forms in japan oh it is
doing tax in the uk is bad enough and
i'm just like if that was
bad how is it in [ __ ] japan oh it's
god awful i hate it i regret it
you know i thought it was bad in the uk
but then now i look back at how
doing taxes on the uk i'm like
everything could be done online yeah
everything can be done online at home
pretty good that's an app you know like
in japan you have to take a [ __ ] bag
full of receipts to like the town ward
and like
yeah go through all of it and like fill
it in yourself oh my god it is the worst
that's why that's why there's no
freelancers in japan because they're
like [ __ ] that i don't want to deal with
that [ __ ]
join the company the worst i will say
though
it was pretty cool the first time i
discovered the hunger and
you know it's cool for 10 seconds until
it becomes a burden yeah it's it's cool
for like the first week you live in here
when i'm like oh i'm i'm
i'm sorry i'm i'm stamping now i'm part
of the culture here guys
yeah let me let me put my signature look
at my clan it's the manny taco plan
that's what it feels like right when
you're [ __ ] stamping your second name
down you're like
making it like a really like traditional
like kind of swirly like
yeah yeah futile japan style stamps it
looks dope
it looks dope i can see why they haven't
like gotten rid of it because it feels
like i feel cultured as i'm stamping my
[ __ ] name down
you know you know you know when you see
like an old in old films where you know
they're writing a letter and they're
[ __ ] stamped down yeah that's what it
feels like every time i
every time i snap down my hand but then
it gets to a point where you live here
for a year and you're just like
[ __ ] sake can we not just go back to
your signature just give me a pen
you know you stamp it and they're like
no it's not good enough you haven't
stamped it enough
what do you mean i can read it oh it's
slightly crooked can you feel the name
again please
okay if it's slightly crooked if there's
slightly not enough ink on it
they just won't accept it yeah also i
remember i filled out like this
three-page document and i made one
mistake and i uh did the the line
through it
and the guy at the the driving license
plate's like you gotta be doodle
yeah i'm like why it's like you've made
a mistake you gotta redo it all right i
mean you can't cross things out here
i'm like i crossed it out though it's
not it's not a hundred percent accuracy
only in japan i'm like
what do you mean you can clearly there
is no 80 in japan only
percent right yeah i'm like you can
clearly make out there is absolutely no
problem here
you know that i don't mean the thing
that i crossed out and you know the
thing
what i meant to put yeah why are you
gonna make me fill out this three-page
document again
because i made one mistake it's like
it's it's like
everything is a [ __ ] like trapeze act
where you [ __ ] up you gotta redo
your whole life yeah just born do life
again reset life
jesus yeah only perfection here i'm
surprised that you know you need to
fill out a document or you're like nope
no license for you come back next day
we do it again basically if you want to
live in japan i hope you like
filling out forms because you are
correctly yeah
correctly because you are no mistake
expect perfection in everywhere
it's like moving here is kind of like
form simulator 2021
honestly but every day
it's exhausting man yeah that's that's
kind of why like i'm dreading these next
few months when we move studios and move
houses we're gonna be i'm gonna be in a
foul mood in like in like october when i
have to move
i'm just gonna not wanna talk to anyone
the [ __ ] you yeah yeah
if we're complaining now about this when
we actually start moving my god
because i know i'm going to lose at
least a week just from this alone so
sorry if you don't get any videos for
like that month
my [ __ ] video schedule is like the
slowest it's ever been because of the
show because of this [ __ ] it's
it shouldn't be like that it's
ridiculous how did normal people
who work nine to fives oh sorry i mean
sorry uh nine to twelves
uh in japan how do they have time to do
this stuff i don't understand because
people don't stop working here and stuff
closes on weekends here so what do they
do i don't understand they take pay
leave
they take a week are you serious they
take a week off to move
oh wait don't they only have by law a
week of
paid holiday anyway
20 whole days so you lose what like
five you lose a quarter of your paid
holiday if you want to move here in
japan
if you want to do that moving as a
luxury
if you want to do anything in japan you
got to take a day off to call them up
and do it yeah exactly that's ridiculous
you want to oh
you know you can't you know if you want
to change your phone provider you've got
to take a day off work how weird is that
what the
[ __ ] it's weird the fact that you can't
just do it like during a lunch break is
ridiculous
yeah it's tragic it really is tragic so
as someone who has moved before joey
what is the moving experience like here
in japan
hell you've already won
japan right i've moved twice now oh
you've moved twice yeah so
the place i'm about to move to will be
my fourth place oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah
yeah but you've moved twice but you've
had four places
well yeah how does that work well i mean
i moved in here and then i moved to
separate times sorry sorry i was like
wait that number
those numbers don't add up two plus two
equals well
well the first time i move when i moved
from australia to japan it was a lot
easier for me because i had helped
i had help from my like my auntie so she
did all the paperwork for me because
oh yeah epic i don't know how to do it
but then she was like all right well now
you know how to do it i'm like
all right what do i do
someone builds a pc for you like great
you can do on your own now yeah yeah
yeah she's like
you've passed the tutorial stage yeah i
hope you're paying attention i'm like
thanks expert expert mode it's not even
like uh
would you like to listen to that again
option i hope you're listening
yeah so the first time when i moved here
was fine but then this
from the second time on when i moved to
you know my own place
yeah it was hell and it's and it's still
hell this is the third time i'm doing it
now and it's it's
not easier at all like the only thing
that makes it easier now is that you
know exactly
the list of things you need to do yeah
but the list of
going but the process of going through
that the time is not anymore
the time is not any more efficient it is
just as time consuming
right no no one wants to improve their
life because they're like well i just i
i do want them
that's what i'm saying right now i've
got asbestos i've got mold but you know
frankly putting up that paper that's
what i'm saying like it's not an
understatement to say
that or not an overreaction to say that
moving in japan is a luxury
yeah and it shouldn't be a luxury it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
that's what that's that's why they're
able to charge the same amount when you
have to renew your contract
which is why we i don't know if we
explain this but the reason we're all
moving
is because when your contract ends for
like your rental period
normally you think it can just easily
roll over and stuff that's in the uk
that's how it does in the uk that's
that's how it did in time
for me yeah that's how i did in most
countries nope you've got to go through
the same process again and pay the same
fees you've got to pay two months of
rent for free yeah no reason
yeah because they want it and it's like
because you've got to [ __ ] you
[ __ ] giving you two months of money
for free for what for this shitty
apartment [ __ ] off
yeah it's ridiculous yeah yeah i hate it
did you use like a moving company the
first time you moved yeah i got a moving
company but
i mean the the moving company we're
using for now the new places like
has like a service where like they'll
come in and like pack it for you like
weirdly enough the moving company is
probably the
easiest thing to sort out yeah okay when
moving it's
everything else that's a pain like the
intel internet is the [ __ ] worst
i can imagine like setting up internet
for a new place is
that's hard in the uk as well yeah it's
like the hardest one yeah because
they're just like they're just
like oh yeah so uk going uh four months
without internet in the new place it's
like
no no i'm [ __ ] not yeah but at least
like
without current price like they'll give
us like a like a kind of portable
or not portable but like a rental wi-fi
kind of thing so you're not like
completely out of internet you just like
so
yeah it still sucks that i have to wait
for like the full price to like kick in
but yeah
yeah i mean yeah the moving company is
weirdly the smoothest
thing sick yeah awesome i'm in the uk
when i moved
all my stuff to my parents house um i
again i was trying to do it as cheap as
possible yeah and there was like a
service
that had like vans but for uber
it's called like any van or something in
the uk right right paid a guy
uh guess how much i it costs to go
basically
from london to north wales like that's
like basically half the uk
right how much think that cost to hire
that van like like one van
just one guy in a van just driving
normally i'd think maybe like
i don't know 300 pounds maybe there's
120 pounds i think i
i paid that sounds as [ __ ] and i was
so [ __ ] scared the whole time when
this when i put my
because this guy was just like all right
what are we doing what we put in the
boxes what are we doing what are we
doing it was just like some guy
who just like again again like uber for
fans wow
he was really nice um my mom was like
yeah he was really nice when he got
there
i was like that just sounds like it was
so cheap and i was like this guy can't
be getting much so i gave him a fat tip
because
he was really nice and was really
helpful uh to my mom that sounds scary
though doesn't it like that's weird that
just calls for some dude
who has all your stuff in his van and
just drives off yeah this is the middle
of nowhere
there was a gps tracker on his car but
again he could just take oh you went
with him
no oh okay oh that's more scary
gave him all my all my valuable stuff
he's like see you later
jesus christ so your laptop your pc yeah
everywhere you go everything
that's that's scary yeah and somehow we
fit all the van and everything and uh
yeah somehow it was fine and it the
service was great paid
it was pretty much cheap as [ __ ] yeah
jesus i'm thinking i'm like the fuel
must have been like
half of that cost like this this man
cannot be getting any money from yeah
yeah
that's why i was like fat tip yeah he
might be living just strictly off tips
yeah i don't know i feel bad but yeah i
mean i don't know like because like
tipping culture i don't know timmy
culture is different everywhere in the
world
right and in the uk it's the uk is like
kind of in the middle i guess
with tipping culture um japan is
non-existent which
you know there are there are times when
i wish that i could tip people in japan
because i get some of the best customer
service here that i've
i've ever had worldwide and i can't tip
people here it's because it's the whole
philosophy
of you know the best customer service
is expected wait what was the tension
that we were on before i started talking
about my event
your movie company right yeah moving
cars i basically just said the moving
company was
doing it oh yeah sure when i moved in
the uk from london back to brighton like
just use gumtree
and i i feel like with with the uk um i
i don't know anyone who's actually used
the moving company everyone's just
knowing a mate whoever laughs yeah
at least one friend has like a giant
i mean that's just pretty our age but i
think when the people use moving
companies are like families yeah just
absurd amounts of stuff that makes sense
i mean i was because
at my age i i when i moved out i
recycled or threw away
probably about seventy percent of my
belongings cause i'm like i don't need
this anymore yeah yeah
but like because i was like oh well i'm
you know i i like uh
i put everything on f for free on
gumtree all my stuff yeah
come get it who wants who wants my
wardrobe who wants my [ __ ] oh yeah
that's what i did with like
without current movies as well there's
like a japanese site we can just throw
like couches and beds
yeah people just come figure people go
on like craigslist like [ __ ]
exactly give things because throwing out
trashy costs [ __ ] money
yeah and like an absurd amount of money
to throw out where i'm just like
why would anyone do that pain in the air
just give it to someone true true i
don't know
[ __ ] i just remembered bang sorry sorry
to [ __ ] on banks again
um you can't i remember i was in uh i
was out
in shibuya and i was out until like 2
a.m
i was like all right well i want to go
home now so i'm going to get a taxi
and i was like great well i've got no
money so i'll just go and quickly go and
get some money from the atm
turns out that after working hours you
just can't withdraw money
so you know if uh [ __ ] me if i was
stranded in the middle of nowhere yeah
right i'll get money have to wait
i have to wait until what 8 a.m until
the banks open up for some reason so the
atms stop [ __ ] work
i've never i don't think i've ever had
to i don't think i've ever had to take
money out like that
i know sometimes i have a good night you
know i spend more than i intended to
i've got no more cash left no big i'll
get some from the atm
right no [ __ ] me [ __ ] me and even if it
is during
working hours i got to pay anyway what
am i paying for it's an atm
there's no one there there's no one in
the machine giving me money is there is
just a small man sleeping in the machine
who's awake during these hours why is it
this much
yeah like like there are some atm like
to to to explain there are some atms in
the uk
that do charge to take money out but
they are like
they're like the like no branded atms
at some sketchy like those are the ones
where like there's probably a man
inside yeah yeah yeah those are the ones
where it's [ __ ]
2 a.m or something you just need some
[ __ ] money out to go to the club or
something and you're like
sure i'll pay five pounds to take out my
20 pound entry fee to this club
whatever i'm drunk enough to do it no no
imagine now imagine that
but for every transaction you do and
that's that's taking out money here in
japan yeah you have to take out a lot of
money
yeah they charge like five bucks i think
each time or something yeah they charge
like just like
five bucks everything to access unless
you go to that
bank's branded atm but even then
sometimes they charge you
yeah because yeah because you have a
limit as to how many times you can take
money out per month but that depends if
if you for some reason you're rich
[ __ ] and you you have x amount
of money in your bank it's free they're
like no no it's on us
you have a lot of money with us we ain't
going to charge
the [ __ ] poor people what the [ __ ]
that's just like what's wrong
it's like everything in this system is
designed to make you hate them damn
capitalism like like when i was
when i when i wanted to get the taxi
home i was like i'm so goddamn lucky
that i ca i have a foreign card that i
just carry on me at emergencies yes
because i'm like you never know
yeah my my foreign my british cards yeah
is just like my get away get out of jail
free card yeah so so
it's like 100 more reliable than using
the card
in the country it was made from like how
does that work my british bank
card works every single atm yeah any
time of the day
whenever and they bet they don't charge
me they just charge me the exchange rate
cost which
i accept you know because i'm changing
the money whatever they got to do that
but you know i i don't i genuinely don't
know how i would have got home that
night
if i if i didn't have my british card
what did you happen easy will do in this
they'll just go to the [ __ ]
manga cafes don't they well no because
that you'd have to pay for the modern
cafe
i mean you've probably seen it before
they literally sleep outside like
stations should be a meltdown [ __ ]
yes or should be a meltdown or something
else but like sometimes i've seen
you know walking past the station or
whatever there's like couples and like
you know businessmen just sleeping
outside of the station waking waiting
for it to wake up
yeah like it's ridiculous absolutely
insanity
like like talking about this now i'm
like i'm i'm really starting to sweat
this year right because
um because of the world situation
haven't been able to travel back to the
uk
yeah and i look at the expiry date on my
card and it's like
it's like creeping up right because it
was it was like because before i moved
up death notes
at least my bank does yeah it sends me
to my uk
address which no one is living in right
now because my parents are in [ __ ]
thailand i'm here in japan
um so my my i'm not gonna say what the
exact day but
it is my is in 2021 my expiry date for
my
british card and i'm just like
i'm i'm starting to swear because i'm
just like [ __ ] man if if i can't travel
back to the uk to get my new cards then
i'm kind of just like resting on my
japanese cards at work
it's 20 23 we good gucci
[ __ ] yeah it's scary
yeah i mean that was a that was a nice
little rant
banks of hell here sorry i'm sure most
people have absolutely no
care in the world about japanese banks
but now you know a lot more well there's
probably a lot
you know there's a lot of audiences of
trash taste who are like one day i want
to live in japan and live that weeb
dream just be prepared well
i i think we've done a good job at least
you know
bigging up the the stuff that is worth
you know giving
honestly honestly and we're brutally
honest about the ship parts
honestly like all things considered
japan is like
i don't know if it's the best but it's
definitely like either comparing the uk
to japan it's been
a [ __ ] amazing place to live and i
don't know if i'll put it as the best
but it's definitely
well the plus is definitely our way the
mind yeah i i think i think i i enjoy
living here yeah i'm right okay
so i mean i'm definitely have enjoyed my
previous
year and a half more than i have in the
uk um we'll we'll see how i am five
years down the line
you know yeah but right now i can i'm
definitely i'm approaching my fifth year
yeah i'm definitely gonna be here for at
least two three more years i think yeah
definitely definitely because i [ __ ]
love it here it's so much fun it's an
amazing country so expect trash taste
for at least another
just just just just don't just don't
tell me i have to move house or
[ __ ] change my internet or change my
phone because i am
uh i'm gonna go just just tell me ahead
of time when that happens because i'll
just [ __ ]
get out of there before i'm like driving
like this this rant is me like mentally
preparing for like
the the month in like the month and this
year that i'm gonna have to dedicate to
moving
yeah i mean paying taxes was way more
like much much more enjoyable than
doing any of the forms i had to do in
japan which is just weird
but anyway you know who doesn't charge
us to use atms are wonderful patrons oh
my god look at them
but look at this guy they live rent free
in our heads
i bet they would charge them to get
their money i bet they have a good
banking system
yeah that's why they're supporting this
guy
i bet this guy can get his bank
statement online
i bet they can play or pay all their
bills online right now of course they
can
hey if you'd like to support this show
that they're doing right now yeah make
sure
make sure to go to patreon.com trash
taste i just look forward to the day
where i don't have to pay my bills by
carrier pigeon injury yeah exactly i
can't wait for it
but thank you so much for watching this
episode of trash taste hope you enjoyed
it don't forget to listen to us on
spotify go to the reddit and check out
the memes
uh oh my god you said it i didn't have
to do it yeah
i did it for once sorry i got to do that
next
thank you so much for watching trash
taste see ya bye
[Music]
you